I WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO
THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ADDRESSING RACIAL DISPARITIES
AND HOUSING- THIS IS A HEARING
BEING HELD JOINTLY BETWEEN THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE IN THE
ASSEMBLY BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE AND I WANT TO THANK
CHAIRMAN GRAYSON FOR HIS
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS- AND I.
LOOK FOR TO HEAR IN A FEW WORDS
FROM HIM- AS INTRODUCTORY
REMARKS I HAVE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING MATTERS DUE TO
ONGOING COVER NINETEEN SAFETY
CONSIDERATIONS WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
FEAR IN THE CHAMBER AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN PERSON. WE ARE
REQUIRING THAT MASS BE WORN AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IF YOU DON'T HAVE A
MASK WE CAN PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU
IT IS THE CUSTOM AND PRACTICE
OF THE HOUSE THAT MEMBERS BE
PROPERLY ATTIRED AND FOR
HEARING WEARING A MASK IS A
REQUIREMENT I'VE BEEN PROPERLY.
ATTIRED FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT
SECTION WRITTEN TESTIMONY CAN
BE SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE
BY EMAILING. A. H. CD WHICH
STANDS FOR THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
COMMITTEE SO IT HCD DOT
COMMITTEE. AT ASSEMBLY DOT CA.
DOT GOV. WE WILL HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT AND THOSE WISHING TO
CALL IN. CAN DO SO BY CALLING
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
USING THE ACCESS CODE TWO FOUR
TWO. SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL
AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. FOR THOSE
CALLING THEN PLEASE ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE THIS
INCLUDES MUTING. YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE. PLEASE KERR
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE. TWO OH EIGHT FIVE AND
OUR STAFF WILL ASSIST YOU. I
WANT TO IN ADVANCE THANK THE
PANELISTS WILL BE TESTIFYING
TODAY. AND ALSO NOTE THAT WE
ARE JOINED BY A NUMBER OF
LEGISLATORS WHO ARE NOT REGULAR
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE. I
UNDERSTAND- FROM SOME OF OUR AT
THE CAUCUSES WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MCCARTY AND GIPSON IN
THE CHAMBER. AND I ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT SENATOR
KAMLAGER WILL BE PARTICIPATING.
VIRTUALLY I ALSO WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT AND ACKNOWLEDGE. A
STUDENT SAM. FAKE PASS AS PART
OF HIS MASTER'S ABODE POLICY
STUDIES AT UC BERKELEY. OUR WHO
HAS BEEN WORKING WITH OUR
HOUSING COMMITTEE STAFF OVER
THE LAST FEW MONTHS TO PULL
TOGETHER THIS HEARING. AND THE
BACKGROUND PAPER. THE
BACKGROUND PAPER AND
BIOGRAPHIES FOR THE PANELISTS
CAN BE FOUND ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. SO IF YOU ARE
SUBSTANTIVE INTRODUCTORY MARKS.
WE KNOW AS WE HAVE BEEN
GRAPPLING WITH OUR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS WITH THE
PANDEMIC AND THIS RECESSION- OF
EQUITY AND DISPARITIES
HARBOURFRONT CENTRE AND THIS IS
A HEARING TO CONSIDER WAYS TO
ADDRESS RACIAL DISPARITIES IN
HOUSING. IT'S CRUCIAL AS WE
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE
DISPARITIES HAVE BEEN PART OF
AN AND DURING LIKE A SEA OF
SYSTEMIC RACISM AND DECADES OF
EXCLUSIONARY POLICY DECISIONS
AT THE FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
LEVELS. CALIFORNIANS OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY FROM OUR BLACK AND
LET NEXT COMMUNITIES. HAVE TOO
OFTEN BEEN DENIED TO. SAFE
HOUSING AFFORDABLE HOUSING BOTH
IN THE RENTAL CONTEXT AND IN
THE HOMEOWNERSHIP CONTEXT.
WHILE HOUSING DISCRIMINATION ON
THE BASIS IS A LEGAL ACCORDING
TO STATE LAW DISPARITIES IN
HOUSING BASED ON RACE OF
CONTINUED. PROGRESS ON CLOSING
EXISTING INEQUITIES HAS BEEN
INCREMENTAL AT BEST. AND WE ALL
KNOW FULL WELL THAT THE RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN HOUSING DON'T
OCCUR IN A VACUUM THEY ARE TIED
TO THE WAY THAT RACISM
DISCRIMINATION AND BIASES
MANIFESTED ACROSS SOCIETY. IN
THE LABOR MARKET IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IN
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS IN
EVERY ASPECT OF CIVIL SOCIETY.
AND THIS IS WHY IT'S SO TIMELY
IMPORTANT FOR POLICY MAKERS TO
BE HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
RIGHT NOW. AS A PANDEMIC AS AT
A DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
COMMUNITIES OF DIVERSITY AND AS
WE NEED TO MAKE RACIAL EQUITY A
PRIORITY AS WE CONSIDER
POLICIES TO SUPPORT FOR JUST
RECOVERY. WE DON'T KNOW WE'VE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO THAT'S OUR
HOPE THIS HEARING WILL SERVE AS
A CALL TO ACTION IF WE TRULY
WANT TO SEE MEANINGFUL PROGRESS
TOWARD ELIMINATING RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN HOUSING. THE
CONVERSATION CANNOT STOP HERE.
AND WITH THAT BEFORE WE TURN
OVER TO THE PANEL SAID LIKE TO
FIRST. OF THANK- THE CHAIR OF
THE BANKING COMMITTEE SOMEONE
HAS BEEN A TREMENDOUS PARTNER
ON HOUSING ISSUES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON. AND ASK IF YOU
LIKE TO MAKE SOME BRIEF REMARKS
BEFORE TODAY'S HEARING. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND AYE AYE A FAKE-
THE CHAIR OF HOUSING COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO ADD. HOUSING
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR TAKING THE
LEAD IN ORGANIZING. THIS VERY%
VERY IMPORTANT HEARING. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK ALL THE PANELISTS
IN ADVANCE FOR THEIR INSIGHTS.
I THINK WE'RE REALLY GOING TO
HAVE. A AN INFORMATIVE AND
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION. I DO ECHO
THE CHAIR STATEMENTS ABOUT THE
URGENCY OF THE CRISIS.
CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE
LOWEST HOME OWNERSHIP RATES IN
THE NATION. FALLING ALMOST 10%
BELOW THE NATIONAL AVERAGE. THE
NUMBER THAT THE NUMBERS ARE
EVEN WORSE FOR LATINA- LET
NECKS AND BLACK RESIDENTS. AT
43% AND 35% RESPECTIVELY. IN
FACT THE RATE OF BLACK HOME
OWNERSHIP IS LOWER TODAY THAN
IT WAS IN NINETEEN SIXTY WHEN
RACIALLY BASED HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION WAS ACTUALLY
LEGAL. THIS IS A TRAVESTY. SO
TODAY'S HEARING WILL TOUCH ON
MANY OF THE TOPICS AND
QUESTIONS THAT. THE BANKING
COMMITTEE IS PAYING ATTENTION
TO RIGHT NOW. HOW DO WE
INTRODUCE MORE FAIRNESS TO
CREDIT SCORES AND HOW THOSE
SCORES ARE USED TO SECURE
HOUSING. HOW DO WE KEEP
FAMILIES FACING FORECLOSURE IN
THEIR HOMES. AND WHAT SHOULD WE
DO ABOUT DISPARITIES. IN THE
MORTGAGE PROCESS THAT CREATE
DISADVANTAGES AND HIGHER RATES
FOR BLACK AND LATIN X.
BORROWERS. THESE ARE SOME VERY
DIFFICULT QUESTIONS. THAT WE
MUST ANSWER. SO WE HAVE POLICY
MAKERS MUST DO MORE. TO MAKE
HOUSING MORE AFFORDABLE AND
MORE ACCESSIBLE. IT IS ONE OF
MY BIGGEST PRIORITIES THIS YEAR
AND AS CHAIR OF THE BANKING
COMMITTEE I ALSO BELIEVE THE
BANKING INDUSTRY. HAS A BIG
ROLE TO PLAY IN BRINGING
CALIFORNIA TO A MORE INCLUSIVE
HOUSING FUTURE. WHETHER IT'S ON
THE FRONT END FINANCING
CRITICAL HOUSING PROJECTS OR-
ON THE MORTGAGE LENDING SIGN.
HELPING PEOPLE ACHIEVE THE
DREAM OF ECONOMIC STABILITY
THROUGH HOME OWNERSHIP. BANKERS
AND LENDERS NEED TO BE A PART
OF THE SOLUTION. I AM HOPEFUL
THAT THROUGH A MIX OF
LEGISLATION AND PARTNERSHIPS
WITH INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS WE
CAN MAKE PROGRESS. I AM LOOKING
FORWARD TO OUR CONVERSATION
TODAY AND LEARNING MORE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND- WITHOUT FURTHER
DO WE WILL PROCEED TO THE FIRST
PANEL- WHICH WILL BE ON
DIVERSIFYING HOME OWNERSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA ALL THE WAY WILL
PROCEED WITH TODAY'S WORLD ASK
EACH PANELIST TO PRESENT FOR
FIVE MINUTES AND THEN WILL HAVE
A FEW MINUTES FOR Q. AND A WITH
MEMBERS- AND- THEN WILL ALSO BE
ASKING PANELISTS FOR POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS IN FINAL
REMARKS SO. UNLESS ANY OF OUR
MEMBERS WANNA MAKE INTRODUCTORY
COMMENTS. I KNOW WELL. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS WOULD LIKE
TO SAY A FEW WORDS AS WE START.
AT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AT
SKIDDED TO JOIN THIS HEARING
IT'S MY FIRST APPEARANCE NUMBER
OF THE BANKING COMMITTEE AND
I'M VERY MUCH LOOKING FORWARD
TO OUR CONVERSATION. I WANT TO
THANK BOTH OF YOU FOR CONVENING
US ON I HAVE THIS CRITICAL
TOPIC WE NOTE THAT DECADES OF
DISCRIMINATORY NEUTRALIZE AND
LENDING POLICIES HAVE LED US TO
A- TWENTY TWENTY ONE REALITY
WITH EXTREME RACIAL DISPARITIES
IN. HOMEOWNERSHIP AND
GENERATIONAL. THAT MUCH IS NOT
IN DISPUTE SO THE CHALLENGE
BEFORE US NOW AS CALIFORNIA
STATE POLICYMAKERS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS. HOW DO WE START
TO REVERSE THOSE DECADES OF
DISCRIMINATORY POLICIES IS
DECADES OF INJUSTICE AND THAT
BEGAN TO LIFT UP. DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THESE ARE TOUGH
CHALLENGES THEIR NOSE EASY
ANSWERS- BUT WE KNOW THAT WE'VE
GOT TO ACT NOW AND WE'VE GOT TO
DIG IN AND LEAD INTO THIS THIS
ISSUE SO REALLY LOOKING FORWARD
TO. HEARING FROM OUR OUR
PANELISTS AND EXPERTS ON
PRACTICAL STEPS THAT WE CAN
TAKE TODAY TO START. MAKING
PROGRESS ON THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU. RIGHT THANK YOU MISS PETER
NORRIS AND LET ME ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GIPSON THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
CHAIRMAN CHU AND ALSO GRAYSON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ONE
CONVENING THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING IT IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY THAT WE HEAR FROM
THIS PANEL OF EXPERTS TO HELP
GUIDE US ON POLICIES THAT WE
SHOULD BE CONSIDERING. IT IS-
IT IS- IT IS UNREASONABLE TO
FEEL AND TO THINK THAT ONE OF
THE AMERICAN DREAM IS
UNREACHABLE AND NOT
UNOBTAINABLE ESPECIALLY IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY IN THE BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITY WHAT IS THE
BECAUSE WHAT IS THE ROOT CAUSE
OF WHY- THEY JUST DID IT THE
DISK. SCHURMAN NATION- IS
TAKING PLACE WHEN IT COMES DOWN
AFTER AMERICA TINO'S- WHEN IT
COMES DOWN HOME OWNERSHIP WHAT
IS PEOPLE HAVE TO MASQUERADING
PUT A FRIEND- TO MASQUERADE AS
THEM IN ORDER JUST TO BE-
CREATES UNFAIR ECKEL EQUITABLE-
REASONABLE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THEM TO GET HOMEOWNERSHIP AND
JUST TO BE TREATED FAIRLY. AND
SO I'M VERY MUCH INTERESTED IN
LISTENING TO THOSE FROM THE
PANEL TO HELP GUIDE THIS
DISCUSSION- AND ALSO AROUND
CREDIT SCORES- AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP PEOPLE- ARE
IN THIS AREA AROUND CREDIT
SCORES BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
AFTER A LOT OF TIMES THE CREDIT
SCORES ARE USED TO KEEP- PEOPLE
OF COLOR DOWN AND BOUND AND NOT
BEING ABLE TO REACH THE
AMERICAN DREAM SO. I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO THIS ROBUST
DISCUSSION AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR CONVENING. IT IS
TIMELY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ARE NOW LET'S TURN TO OUR
PANEL. AGAIN ON DIVERSIFYING
HOMEOWNERSHIP IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR FIRST WITNESS IS AN
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR CITY AND
REGIONAL PLANNING AT UC
BERKELEY. WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
PROFESSOR CAROLINE A READ TO
TESTIFY. IF WE CAN GO TO OUR
MODERATOR YOU COULD ALLOW THE
PROFESSOR TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
AND CAN ALSO GET THE PERMISSION
TO SHARE MY SCREEN HOPEFULLY
EVERYBODY CAN. IF IT'S POSSIBLE
TO TURN UP THE VOLUME OR IF YOU
COULD SPEAK MORE CLOSELY TO
YOUR MICROPHONE IT'S HARD TO
HEAR YOU. TANK YOU JUST A
SECOND HERE. IS THAT BETTER
THAT IS YES. AS SAM AM I GOING
TO BE ABLE TO SHARE MY SCREEN
ARE YOU GOING TO SHARE IT FOR
ME. WE CAN SEE YOU NOW. AND
ACTUALLY GO. AND WE CAN SEE
YOUR SCREEN FIVE TERRIFIC-
THANK YOU SO MUCH I THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CHIU AND
GRAYSON FOR INVITING ME TO TALK
TODAY IF YOU COULD SPEAK UP
JUST AS LOUDLY AS YOU CAN- THAT
WOULD BE VITAL. SURE THANKS FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TODAY I'M GOING TO GIVE
YOU A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT AND
THEN PROVIDE SOME- SUGGESTED
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS. I'M THE
FIRST. POINT THAT I WANT TO
MAKE IS THAT. HOMEOWNERSHIP IS
INCREASINGLY OUT OF REACH FOR
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. THIS IS A
SLIDE THAT SHOWS YOU THE CHANGE
IN THE BOTTOM THIRD TIER OF
HOUSE VALUES. WHICH ARE
GENERALLY CONSIDERED MORE ENTRY
LEVEL HOMES. AND YOU CAN SEE
THAT IN CITIES LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO EVEN ENTRY LEVEL
HOMES NOW ARE SELLING FOR OVER
A MILLION DOLLARS- IN LOS
ANGELES AND OAKLAND THE ENTRY
LEVEL HOME IS. TOPPING SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND
SO ONE CHALLENGE WE FACE IN
EXPANDING ACCESS TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP IS CERTAINLY THE
PRICE OF HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE LACK OF- MODERATE-
SUPPLIED MODERATE COST THE
PLIGHT OF HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES. WE SEE THIS IN
MANIFESTING IN LOWER AND LOWER
ACCESS TO HOMEOWNERSHIP
PARTICULARLY FOR MODERATE AND
MEDICAL INCOME FAMILIES. THIS
SLIDE SHOWS YOU THE CHANGE AND-
HOME SALES TO BORROWERS AT
DIFFERENT INCOME LEVELS AT 80%
A 100% AND A 120% OF A. M. I.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT IN ALMOST
EVERY LARGE METROPOLITAN AREA
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF
SACRAMENTO AND FRESNO. WE SEEN
A DECLINE IN OUR FAMILIES WHO
ARE EARNING AROUND THE MEDIAN
INCOME BEING ABLE TO ACCESS
HOMEOWNERSHIP. THE DECLINES ARE
EVEN PRONOUNCED AMONG THOSE WHO
ARE AT A 120% A IN MY IN A LOT
OF OUR COASTAL CITIES. I THINK
A BOTH ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU AND
GRAYSON REFER TO THIS BUT WE
SEE THIS ALSO MANIFEST IN
SEVERE RACIAL DISPARITIES IN
WHO HAS ACCESS TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP. THE BLACK
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA'S JUST AROUND THIRTY
SIX PERCENT- THIRTY POINTS
LOWER THAN THAT FOR NON
HISPANIC WHITES BUT WE ALSO SEE
SIGNIFICANT DISPARITIES IN THE
HISPANIC LIVE NEXT POPULATION.
I'M THE ASIAN A HOMEOWNERSHIP
RATE IS HIGHER BUT I WILL SAY
THAT FOR SOME ASIAN SUB
COMMUNITIES WE ALSO SEE
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP. UP WHAT'S GOING
ON HERE ASSEMBLY MEN MEMBER
GROUP GIPSON ASKED WHAT WITH
THE ROOT CAUSES I WOULD ARGUE%
THAT THE ROOT CAUSES OF FALL
ALONG THE ENTIRE CONTINUUM OF
THE HOMEOWNERSHIP ACCESS AND
BENEFITS CONTINUUM. I'M GOING
EVERYWHERE FROM CREDIT SCORES
AND WEALTH TO MORTGAGE ACCESS
TO APPRAISALS TO
SUSTAINABILITY. TO GIVE YOU
JUST A COUPLE OF KEY POINTS
HERE- IN CALIFORNIA THE NETWORK
FOR NON HISPANIC WHITE
HOUSEHOLDS IS THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
COMPARED TO ONLY FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND FOUR HOUSEHOLDS OF
COLOR. WE KNOW THAT BLACK
BORROWERS HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
LOWER MEDIAN FIKE OF CREDIT
SCORES ARE COMPARED TO NON
HISPANIC WHITE BORROWERS A
DIFFERENCE OF ABOUT SEVENTY
FIVE POINTS WHICH IS
SUBSTANTIAL. THEY'RE ALSO MUCH
LESS LIKELY TO HAVE A CREDIT
SCORE ABOUT 21% OF BLACK
POPULATION HAS NO CREDIT SCORE
COMPARED TO ABOUT 12% OF NON
HISPANIC WHITES. EXCLUSIONARY
ZONING HAS A ROLE TO PLAY IN
APPROXIMATELY THREE QUARTERS OF
CALIFORNIA NEIGHBORHOODS LESS
THAN 5% OF LOANS GO TO BLACK
HOME BUYERS. WE KNOW THAT
MORTGAGE ACCESS AND DENIAL
RATES ARE HIGHER FOR BLACKS AND
HISPANICS FOR BLACKS DENIAL
RATES ARE TWICE THAT FOR NON
HISPANIC WHITES- AT 16% AND FOR
HISPANICS- THE DENIAL RATE IS
12% I'M THIS ALSO PLAYS OUT IN
PRICING OF MORTGAGES ON AVERAGE
BLACK HOMEOWNERS ARE PAYING
THIRTY THREE BASIS POINTS
HIGHER IN THEIR MORTGAGES THAN
NON HISPANIC WHITE HOMEOWNERS.
AT THIS TRANSLATES INTO
DIFFERENT TAX BENEFITS BOTH THE
MORTGAGE INTEREST TAX DEDUCTION
AND PROP THIRTEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY BENEFIT
HIGHER INCOME NON HISPANIC
WHITES AND THOSE WHO OWN THEIR
HOMES LONGER. APPRAISALS I
THINK THAT'S GOTTEN A LOT OF
RETENTION RECENTLY- HOMES IN
BLACK NIGHBORHOODS ARE UNDER
VALUED BY AN AVERAGE OF ABOUT
FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND HOUSEHOLDS OF COLOR DUE TO
HIGHER LABOR MARKET RISK AND
LOWER SAVINGS ARE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO FALL OUT OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND NOT BE ABLE
TO SUSTAIN THE HOMES THAT THEY
ARE ABLE TO GET INTO. WHAT ARE
THE POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS JUST
VERY BRIEFLY A COVERT NINETEEN
IS HAVING A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON HOMEOWNERS OF COLOR.
WE ARE UNLIKELY TO SEE THE SAME
LEVELS OF FOR CLOSURE AS WE SAW
AFTER THE LAST CRISIS IN PART
DUE TO FORBEARANCE PROGRAMS AND
IN PART BECAUSE HOUSING VALUES
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE GONE UP
MEANING THAT HOMEOWNERS IN
DISTRESS ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO SELL THEIR HOMES. I'M BUT
THIS HAS SIGNIFICANT
IMPLICATIONS FOR RACIAL
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATES AND
SUSTAINABILITY AND SO ONE IS TO
THINK ABOUT A RESCUE FUND TO
SUPPORT HOMEOWNERS WHO WANT TO
STAY IN THEIR HOMES BUT WHO ARE
FACING LONG TERM INCOME
DISRUPTIONS DUE TO COPE AT
NINETEEN. UP WE DO HAVE
EVIDENCE AND- EXAMPLES OF THESE
KINDS OF PROGRAMS AND THEY SHOW
THAT THEY BOTH HELP PEOPLE KEEP
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOME AND ALSO-
IMPROVE SUBSEQUENT EMPLOYMENT
OUTCOMES. OVER THE LONGER TERM
WE NEED TO EXPAND PRODUCTION
AND THE SUPPLY OF MODERATE AND
MEDICAL MIDDLE INCOME A MARKET
RATE HOUSING- THE SUPPLY ISSUE
HERE IS CLEARLY RELATED TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP GAPS. AND WE NEED
A RENEWED COMMITMENT TO
ADDRESSING RACIAL AND IN
PARTICULAR BLACK HOMEOWNERSHIP
GAPS. THERE I THINK WE COULD
THINK ABOUT A BACKSTOP OR
GUARANTEE FOR LOW COST MORTGAGE
ORIGINATIONS PERHAPS DELIVER
THROUGH CDF EYES IN THE STATE.
I THINK THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY
TO THINK ABOUT OUR LOW COST
FINANCING PRODUCT TO SUPPORT
TENANT OPPORTUNITY TO PURCHASE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE IN PLACE IN A
LOT OF CALIFORNIA CITIES. AND
THEN I THINK WE NEED MUCH
STRONGER OVERSIGHT AND AUDIT OF
PRACTICES TRANSPARENCY IN BOTH
CREDIT SCORING AN APPRAISAL
ALGORITHMS TO ENSURE THAT BOTH
CONSCIOUS AND UNCONSCIOUS BIAS
AREN'T PLAYING OUT IN- THOSE
MECHANISMS. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
WHAT'S NOW HERE FROM OUR SECOND
SPEAKER WHO IS THE ASSISTANT
PROFESSOR IN URBAN PLANNING AT
UCLA. PROFESSOR JOSE LOYA. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE A. ACCESS TO
SHARE MY SCREEN. WE COULD SEE
YOU AND YOU CAN SEE SHARES
GOING. OKAY GREAT. ALL THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE. OCT. IT'S NOT
LETTING ME SHARE MY SCREEN.
IT'S OKAY SORRY ABOUT THAT I
GUESS IT'S NOT LETTING ME SO
I'LL HAVE TO TALK TO MYSELF
ONLY I HAD HAD A FEW SLIDES SO
IT'S OKAY- SO I APOLOGIZE TO
EVERYONE FOR NOT BEING ABLE TO
SHARE MY SCREEN A GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE MY NAME'S WILL SET
LARA- TEN TODAY I'M ACTUALLY
GONNA DISCUSS- A TAIL END OF
WHAT CARE. OF CARE- CAROLINE
ARE YEAH CAROLINE ARE
GODLINESS- DISCUSSED EARLIER-
AND I'M GONNA FOCUS MORE ON
MORTGAGE ACCESS STILL A MAJOR
CONVENTION OF HOMEOWNERSHIP AS
ACCESS TO CREDIT FOR MINORITIES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
SO LOOKING AT A VERY SIMILAR
DATA SAID THAT CAROLINE USED
OUT FOR HER TABLES AND FIGURES-
I'M GONNA DISCUSS THE TWO
THOUSAND THE READ MORE RECENT
TRENDS AS IT RELATES TO. OUR
MORTGAGE ACCESS FOR MINORITY
BORROWERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND SO IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OR LOOKING AT
THE MOST RECENT DATA FROM THE
HOME MORTGAGE DISCLOSURE ACT
DATA- THAT- INCORPORATES ALL
80% OF ALL MORTGAGES IN
CALIFORNIA WE WERE STARTING TO
SEE LARGE ETHNO RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO
MORTGAGE CREDIT ARE SIMILAR TO
THE LEVEL THAT WE SAW ACTUALLY
PRE. THE GREAT RECESSION FROM
200-042-2000 SIX IN FACT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN- WE'RE
BEGINNING TO SEE THAT LATIN
ACCENT BLACK HOME SEEKERS-
OBTAINABLE A HIGH COST AND-
OBTAIN A HIGH COST LOAN ABOUT
20% OF THE TIME UP RELATIVE TO
ASIAN WHITE BORROWERS THAT ONLY
GET A HIGH COST PHONE AT ABOUT
10% OF THE TIME. THIS IS
STARTING TO RESEMBLE THE TRENDS
THAT WE STARTED TO SEE OR THE
TRENDS THAT WE SAW PRE THE
GREAT RECESSION OR DURING THE
HOUSING. BUBBLE AROUND THE
COUNTRY. IN A- TO THAT- WERE
ALSO STAR TO SEE THIS ALARMING
TREND FOR LOW INCOME BORROWERS.
AS THEY'RE ALSO MORE LIKELY-
ALMOST. CHEST AND IT'S NOT 20%
OFF 15% MORE LIKELY TO GET HIGH
COST LOAN IN HIGH INCOME
BORROWERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THE
NEIGHBORHOOD LEVELS- WE SEE AN
EVEN LARGER TREND AS BLACK AND
BROWN NEIGHBORHOODS. ARE LATINO
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE AGAIN MORE
LIKELY TO ABSORB THESE HIGH
COST LOANS SIMILAR SIMILAR TO
THE TRANS PRE THE GREAT
RECESSION. IN FACT WHEN WE LOOK
AT PREDOMINATE MINORITY
COMMUNITIES. ABOUT 20% OF ALL
LOANS IN THOSE COMMUNITIES ARE
NOW HIGH COST LOANS. RELATIVE
TO A COMPARED TO ABOUT 10% IN
PREDOMINANTLY WHITE COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
INSTEAD OF FINALLY WHEN WE LOOK
AT LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE SEE THE SAME
TREND. AS IT RELATES TO ETHNO
RACIAL DISPARITIES. IN
HOMEOWNERSHIP. IN TERMS OF
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT ACCESS TO GO TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP. THE LARGEST
VEHICLE FOR GENERATING THIS
WEALTH IS TO THE MORTGAGE
MARKET. AND SO WE HAVE TO START
TO CONSIDER DIFFERENT WAYS ONE
AS CARILLO AS AS- I KEEP MONEY
SAFE CATALINA A CARELESS.
DISCUSSED IS WE NEED TO START
SLOWING DOWN THE APPRECIATION
OF HOMES UP BECAUSE OF THE
ETHNO RACIAL WEALTH GAP OF
MINORITY BORROWERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ARE
YOU IT'S JUST A SIMPLY BECOMING
LESS AND LESS AFFORDABLE FOR
THOSE GROUPS AND SO FIGURING
OUT WAYS TO SLOW DOWN- THIS
TYPE OF APPRECIATION WOULD HAVE
DRAMATIC EFFECTS BECAUSE-
MINORITIES ARE UTILIZING OR
OBTAINING HIGHER LEVELS OF HIGH
COST LOANS. THAT ARE JUST MUCH
MORE PROBLEMATIC OF FOR THE
LONG TERM- PROSPECT OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP FOR MINORITY
COMMUNITIES- AS WE SAW ON THE
GREAT RECESSION IS HAD
DESPERATE IMPACT SO EVEN THOUGH
IT'S CAROLINE- DISCUSSED AS IT
PERTAINS TO COLBY. WE MAY NOT
SEE IT AS HIGH LEVELS OF
FORECLOSURE BECAUSE OF THE POOR
PARENTS ISSUES WE STILL CAN SEE
VERY LARGE LONG TRM EFFECTS OF
THESE HIGH COST LOANS BECAUSE
YOU'RE BEING ABSORBED IT'S SUCH
SEGREGATED. AND PER DOMINO
ALREADY NEIGHBORHOODS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
ARE FOR PANEL BEFORE Q. IN A-
IS THE DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA
POLICY. AT THE CENTER FOR
RESPONSIBLE LENDING. RESCALE
TAURUS. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
CHURCH TO ENSURE GRAYSON AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEES ON HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT BANKING
AND FINANCE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TO HIS
HEARING I AM THE CALIFORNIA
POLICY DIRECTOR THE CENTER FOR
RESPONSIBLE LENDING C. R. L.
WHICH IS A POLICY AFFILIATE OF
SELF HELP SELF HELP IS ONE OF
THE NATION'S LARGEST NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS IN OVER FORTY
YEARS HAS CREATED ASSET
BUILDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS RURAL
COMMUNITIES WOMEN AND FAMILIES
OF COLOR. SOMETIMES THE
NINETEEN CALIFORNIA CREDIT
UNION BRANCHES SERVE JUST OVER
SIXTY THOUSAND MEMBERS IN THE
STATE. I'M OWNERSHIP IS A KEY
PILLAR OF THE AMERICAN DREAM
AND THIS IS THE PRIMARY WAY
THAT MOST MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES
BUILD WEALTH AND ECONOMIC
STABILITY. I'M EQUITY ACCOUNTS
469% OF AMERICAN FAMILY WELL
WHICH IS ESPECIALLY SIGNIFICANT
FOR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WELL
HOME EQUITY ACCOUNTS 439% OF
WHITE HOUSEHOLD WEALTH IT
REPRESENTS 53% OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS. FROM MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES AND PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
PARTICULAR HOME REPRESENTS ONE
OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT ASSETS
AT A FAMILY MAY EVER OWNED. AND
THE EQUITY IN THEIR HOMES
CONSTITUTES A LARGER SHARE OF
PERSONAL WEALTH. WIDESPREAD
ACCESS TO LOW COST FAIRLY
STRUCTURED CREDIT IS A CRITICAL
FOR BUILDING FAMILY WEALTH
CLOSING THE RACIAL WEALTH GAP
IN SUSTAINING THE HOUSING
MARKET OVERALL. THIS IN TURN
CONTRIBUTE SIGNIFICANTLY TO OUR
OVERALL ECONOMY. YET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PURCHASE
MAINTAINED AND REFINANCE A HOME
STILL HAS NOT REACHED
SIGNIFICANTPORTIONS A LITTLE
MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES AND
BLACK AND BROWN COMMUNITIES.
TODAY'S HUESO HOMEOWNERSHIP
DISPARITIES ARE THE RESULT OF A
TROUBLED HISTORY OF RACISM AND
DISCRIMINATION IN THE MORTGAGE
ECOSYSTEM. IN FACT THE BLACK
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE IS STILL AT
LEVELS SIMILAR TO WHERE IT WAS
FIFTY YEARS AGO WHEN THE
FEDERAL. FAIR HOUSING ACT WAS
FIRST PASSED. WE KNOW THAT.
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATES ARE LOWERED
NATIONAL. BUT STILL A GREAT
AMOUNT OF WHITE AMERICANS. HAVE
THIS OPPORTUNITY THAN PEOPLE OF
COLOR. THE DISPARITY IN HOME
OWNERSHIP IS A MAIN DRIVER OF
THE RACIAL WEALTH GAP. THE
MEDIAN WHITE FAMILY HAS TEN
TIMES THE WEALTH OF THE MEDIAN
BLACK FAMILY AT EIGHT TIMES THE
WEALTH OF THE MEDIAN LATINO
FAMILY. FAMILIES OF COLOR HAVE
NOT BEEN AFFORDED THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES TO BUILD WEALTH
THROUGH FEDERALLY SUPPORTED
INVESTMENTS IN HOMEOWNERSHIP.
AND WE'RE DEVASTATED BY THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT FINANCIAL CRISIS
WHEN BLACK AND LATINO FAMILIES
LOST. ONE TRILLION DOLLARS IN
WEALTH FROM UNNECESSARY
FORECLOSURE. AND THIS IS JUST
THE PAINFUL BACKDROP UP TO THE
CLUB IN NINETEEN TEND TO MAKE
WHICH IS WORSE THAN TE
ECONOMIC INEQUALITY IN THIS
COUNTRY. THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE TWO AMERICAS HAS
GROWN EVEN MORE STARK AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC.
FAMILIES WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING
FROM HOME SEEING THEIR WEALTH
GROW DUE TO STOCK MARKET
SURGES. IN INCREASING HOME
PROPERTY VALUES. AND ON THE
OTHER SIDE WE HAVE LOW WAGE
WORKERS AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
BECOMING. ESSENTIAL WORKERS
FACING HEIGHTENED COOLEY
NINETEEN RISK AT WORK MANY
FALLING ILL AND BRING THE VIRUS
HOME TO THEIR LOVED ONES. FOR
THEIR RISK THESE WORKERS ARE
REPAID WITH LOW WAGES AND
NEGLIGIBLE BENEFITS THEY'RE IN
ADEQUATE TO COVER LIFE'S
ESSENTIALS. LET ALONE TO ALLOW
FOR ANY TYPE OF SAVINGS. IN
ADDITION BE SPILLWAYS HAVE BASS
MASSIVE REDUCTIONS IN WORKING
HOURS WE JUST CUTS.
UNEMPLOYMENT FOOD PANTRY LINES
AND THREATS OF EVICTION.
DESPITE FEDERAL EFFORTS LIKE
THOSE THE CARES. MANY BARS. TO
STRUGGLE WITH THEIR MORTGAGES
WITH AROUND FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND BORROWERS AT LEAST
THREE MONTHS PAST DUE AND NOT
IN FORBEARANCE. IN CALIFORNIA
SOME OF THE SAME AREAS HIT
HARDEST BY THE PREVIOUS HOUSING
CRISIS OREGON EXPERIENCE
EXPERIENCING ELEVATED
DELINQUENCY RATES ESPECIALLY IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE AND CENTRAL
VALLEY. RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
THERE ARE RACIAL DISPARITIES
AND WHO HAS STRUGGLED TO KEEP
UP WITH MORTGAGE PAYMENTS
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND THAT
BLACK HOMEOWNERS HAVE BASED
GREATER HARDSHIP IN DOING SO.
OVER THE LAST YEAR. WE MUST
LEARN THE LESSONS OF THE PAST
AND TAKE ACTION TO PREVENT THE
FURTHER WIDENING OF THE RACIAL
WEALTH GAP. AS HOMEOWNERSHIP
DISPARITIES ARE ESSENTIAL
BECAUSE THE LONG TERM EQUITY.
POLICYMAKERS MUST TAKE ACTION
NOW TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF ME
WAS FOR CLOSURES THAT OCCUR
THIS TIME AROUND. STRUGGLING
FAMILIES NEED ASSISTANCE AND WE
CAN HELP DELIVER IT. STRUCTURAL
CHANGES ARE CRUCIAL TO PREVENT
THE PANDEMIC RECOVERED FROM
LIGHTING THE GAP BETWEEN OUR
TWO AMERICA'S. THANK YOU FOR
INVITING STERILE TO PROVIDE
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
CONTINUED DISCUSSION TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS ON THE OSCAR OF
THE COMMITTEE IF ANYONE HAS
QUESTIONS. YOU MISTER GIBSON I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
HAVE A QUESTION FOR MISS
TOURISM WHAT OF WHAT CAN
CALIFORNIA DO TO ENSURE THAT
LOW INCOME CONSUMERS HAVE
GREATER ACCESS TO LENDING. AND
REASONABLE THE COURSE BECAUSE
CREDIT IS STILL A VERY REAL
ISSUE- AND UNDERSERVED AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR SO WHAT
CAN WE DO IN TERMS OF GETTING
ACCESS TO LENDING. SURE SO I
THINK THAT- WE DO NEED MORE
TARGETED AID SPECIFICALLY- TO
OVERCOME DISCRIMINATION IN THE
HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITY TO
START WITH- RESEARCH FROM
FREDDIE MAC IN THE URBAN
INSTITUTE DEMONSTRATES THAT
THERE ARE MILLIONS OF MARKETS
READY. FARMERS OF COLOR TODAY
BASED ON THE CURRENT CREDIT
SCORES AND THEIR DEBT TO INCOME
RATIOS BUT THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR DOWN
PAYMENT SO THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF DOWN PAYMENT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS THAT EXIST- BUT THEY
COULD BE MORE TARGETED
ESPECIALLY TO GET. THESE FUNDS
INTO THE HANDS OF FIRST
GENERATION HOME BUYERS SO
PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE THE FIRST
AND YOU KNOW IN THEIR AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY WE KNOW THAT BLACK
AND BROWN FARMERS GENERALLY DO
NOT COME FROM FAMILIES. THAT
HAVE LEGACIES OF BUILDING AND
PASSING ON INTERGENERATIONAL
WEALTH AND SO TARGETING
ASSISTANCE OF THIS POPULATION
WOULD HELP TO ENSURE CONSUMERS
WHO ARE MORTGAGE READY TODAY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD
AS WELL. BUT IN ADDITION TO
THAT I WOULD SAY THAT WE HAVE
TO CONSIDER HOW A PERSON
BECOMES HOME BUYER READY IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND THIS IS RELATED
TO THEIR INTERACTIONS WITH THE
CREDIT SYSTEM. BEFORE THEY
MIGHT EVEN BE CONSIDERING
BUYING A HOUSE SO STARTING FROM
FROM VERY YOUNG AGES ONCE
SOMEONE STARTS INTERACT WITH
CREDIT WE HAVE TO ENSURE THAT
THE PRODUCTS THAT ARE ON THE
MARKET- ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO
HELP BUILD THEM UP FOR SUCCESS
AND SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT.
ACCESS ACCESS TO CREDIT OUR
PRODUCTS LIKE SMALL DOLLAR
LOANS THAT THESE ARE NOT
SETTING UP CONSUMERS FOR
FAILURE AND THEN A LARGER
ECOSYSTEM OF CREDIT CANNOT BE
PREDATORY AND SETTLING PEOPLE
WITH YEARS OF DEBT THAT THEY
CAN'T GET OUT OF. AND IT IS
HARMING THEIR CREDIT AND THEN
POSITION THEM NOT POSITIONING
THEM IN A WAIT TO BE HOME BUYER
READY SO I THINK THAT WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT SOME OF THOSE OTHER
ISSUES THAT ARE RELATED. TO
CREDIT AND NOT JUST- IN THE
MORTGAGE SPACE SPECIFICALLY AND
THEN. SHE'S LIKE STUDENT AT
WHICH IS A HUGE SORRY A HUGE
BARRIER TO HOMEOWNERSHIP FOR
MILLIONS OF INDIVIDUALS- AND
THIS REALLY HAS TO BE ADDRESSED
BECAUSE RATHER THAN LIFTING
PEOPLE OUT OF POVERTY. AND
PROVIDING ACCESS TO THE MIDDLE
CLASS ASK YOU KNOW THE STUDENT
IS THAT FURTHER ENTRENCH. THE
RACIAL WEALTH. AND PREPARE IN
THIS OF POVERTY THAT IS RESULT.
FROM THE- LACK OF. TO AND CAP.
INTO FOUR CREDIT. SO WE NEED
BOLD ACTION SUCH AS ACROSS THE
BOARD STUDENT DEBT FORGIVENESS-
IN ORDER TO REALLY GET TO THE
HEART OF WHAT IS KEEPING. SO
MANY PEOPLE FROM BEING ABLE TO
BECOME HOME. BUYER READY. TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THESE
OPPORTUNITIES US WAS A BANK
TELLER MUCH REQUESTED BECAUSE I
BELIEVE AND- GENERATIONAL
WEALTH AND THE ONLY WAY YOU'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT. IF
WE TEAR DOWN SOME THE BEAR IS
NOT THAT WE'RE NOT AND IN THE
MIDST OF OPPORTUNITY WE CAN
TEAR DOWN THE BARRIERS. TO
CREATE THAT GENERATIONAL WEALTH
I'M IN OUR COMMUNITY SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OTHER QUESTIONS. THIS
FEATURE. IN THIS IS I THINK
POTENTIALLY QUESTION FOR ALL OF
OUR PANELISTS AND YOU SURFACED
SOME POTENTIAL POLICY PROPOSALS
I INCLUDING IN MORTGAGE
GUARANTEE PROGRAMS TEN AND KIND
OF YOU TO BUY TO RENT
EXCITEMENT BY PROGRAMS AT
MORTGAGE INCREASING MARKET
ACCESS AT PROGRAMS- TO HELP
SUPPORT ACCESS TO CREDIT CENTER
ARE THERE SPECIFIC EXAMPLES- IN
OTHER STATES ARE AND EVEN HAVE
LOCAL CALIFORNIA. FIVE
MUNICIPALITIES OF PROGRAMS THAT
HAVE BEEN VERY EFFECTIVE AND
ARE ACTUALLY WORKING IS THERE
IS THERE MODEL THAT WE CAN
POINT TO AND TRY TO EMULATE HER.
HAPPY FOR ANY OF THE PANELISTS
TO A TO SPEAK UP IF YOU LIKE.
MAYBE THIS IS CAROLINA MAYBE
I'LL GO. FIRST AND THEN I'M
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
EMPHASIZE THAT- I TOTALLY AGREE
WITH. THAT THE PANELISTS
TAURUSES REMARKS THAT WE NEED
TO SORT OF TACKLE THIS OF ALONG
THE WHOLE ENTIRE SPECTRUM- WE
DO HAVE GREAT MODELS AND IN
FACT SELF HELP- AND CENTER FOR
RESPONSIBLE LENDING. DID
INCREDIBLY INTERESTING
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT CALLED
THE COMMUNITY ADVANTAGE PROGRAM
WHERE THEY SHOW THAT YOU COULD
DELIVER WITH A VERY LOW SORT OF
GUARANTEED GOVERNMENT BACKSTOP.
YOU COULD DELIVER ACCESS TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP TO LOWER INCOME
AND- LOWER CREDIT SCORE
BORROWERS AND THAT THEY COULD
BUILD WEALTH AND THAT THEY
COULD KEEP THAT HOMEOWNERSHIP
SUSTAINABLE- I ALSO THINK THAT
THERE'S OTHER MODELS LIKE-
STATE LEVEL COMMUNITY
REINVESTMENT ACT. OR GREATER
OVERSIGHT OVER THE BANKING
INDUSTRY GREATER INCENTIVES UP
FOR LENDING INSTITUTIONS TO
REACH INTO OUR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR OTHER UNDERSERVED AREAS-
EVENT BUT I THINK IT'S ALSO
GOING TO TAKE. SOME INVESTMENT
FROM THE STATE GOVERNMENT TO
HELP OVERCOME. SOME OF THESE
HISTORICAL DISADVANTAGES.
AGREED AND THANK YOU FOR THAT I
WOULD LOVE TO GET SOME MORE.
INFORMATION ON IT HE SAID
ATTEMPT THE DEMONSTRATOR
PROJECT THROUGH THE HELP HELP
CENTER IF THAT'S NOT POSSIBLE.
WOULD BE VERY NICE IT'S NOT.
YEAH I. JUST LIKE A COULD I ADD
THAT- THERE ARE IS THE WORK OF
THE K. HOUSING FINANCE. AND
THEY DO HAVE A PROGRAM THE MY
HOME DOWN PAYMENT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM WHICH WAS INSTITUTED
UNDER THE FORMER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR TINA BOHMAN PETERSON
WHO IS DEEPLY COMMITTED TO FAIR
HOUSING AND FOR LENDING- AND SO
UNDER HER LEADERSHIP TELL HFA
WAS ACTUALLY ONE OF THE FIRST
AID AGENCIES O ADOPT THE
AFFIRMATIVELY AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHERING. FAIR HOUSING
INITIATIVES- AND SO THIS IS A
VERY GREAT- DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM AND IT HAS
SERVED THOUSANDS OF FIRST TIME
HOME BUYERS THE MAJORITY OF
WHOM ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR SO I
WOULD SAY THAT- THE STATE
SHOULD DO AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
TO SUPPORT THAT WORK. CONTINUE
THAT COMMITMENT TO FOR LEADING
INTO FOUR HOUSING TO CONTINUE
TO GIVE PEOPLE A FIRST TIME
HOME BUYERS THE OPPORTUNITY- TO
BECOME HOMEOWNERS. THANK YOU
FOR THOSE ANSWERS ARE LIKE TO
GO TO OUR A FULL CHAIR MISTER
BURSON. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS FOR YOUR
QUESTION ON MODELS THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST TO WE COULD
REPLICATE- BUILDING OFF OF THAT
ARE THERE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
BANKS OR EVEN OTHER FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS. TO MAKE HOME
OWNERSHIP MORE ACCESSIBLE AND
THAT THAT COULD BE TO ANY OF
THE PANELISTS. SO I WOULD SAY
ABSOLUTELY I WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE
MOST ROBUST COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION THAT WORKS. AND
PARTNERING WITH THEM TO SORT OF
GET THESE CREDIT PRODUCTS-
RESPONSIBLE LOANS TO
COMMUNITIES I THINK IS A IS A
VERY- STRONG MODEL THAT WE'RE
USING IN THE SMALL BUSINESS
SPACE WITH A CALIFORNIA
REBUILDING FUND AND SO MAYBE
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO THINK
OF A SIMILAR FUND. BUT DIRECTED
SPECIFICALLY AT HOMEOWNERSHIP
FOR FIRST TIME AND OTHER- AS
LOW INCOME OR BORROWERS OF
COLOR. I AM I WOULD SECOND
THOSE CALL- COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS ARE MISSION DRIVEN
BUT INSTITUTIONS- AND SUPPORT
FOR THEIR PROGRAMS AGAIN WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
MORTGAGE READY BARBERS AND THE
ONLY. THING BLOCKING THEM FROM
BECOMING HOMEOWNERS IS THAT
DOWN PAYMENT- AND SO I THINK
THAT THE EXTENT TO WHICH WE CAN
SUPPORT THE WORK OF CDFI IS TO
GET- RESPONSIBLY STRUCTURED
LOAN AND CREDIT PRODUCTS INTO
THE HANDS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
READY. I WOULD ALSO GO A LONG
WAY IN HELPING TO CLOSE THE
WEALTH GAP IN TERMS OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT I THERE WAS
ONE OTHER ISSUE AREA AND
RESEARCHERS AT. THAT BURKE WAS
OFFERING PLAN BELONG INSTITUTE.
FOUND THAT CITIES WITH HIGH
LEVELS OF SINGLE FAMILY ZONING
OFTEN DISPLAY PATTERNS OF
SOCIAL. ECONOMIC AND RACIAL
EXCLUSION. SO HOW DOES THE
STATE'S LACK OF DIVERSE HOUSING
CONTRIBUTE- OR AT LEAST THE
TYPES OF HOUSING CONTRIBUTE TO
THE LACK OF DIVERSITY IN
HOMEOWNERSHIP- I GUESS WHAT I'M
ASKING. EVEN MORE DETAIL AS-
COULD THE CONSTRUCTION OF FOUR
PLEXUS COTTAGE TOWARDS TWN
HOUSES. OF WHICH ARE MORE
NATURALLY AFFORDABLE TO A
BROADER RANGE OF CALIFORNIANS
PROMOTE A MORE DIVERSE HOME
OWNERSHIP PATTERN WHICH
ADDRESSES GENERATIONAL WEALTH.
SO ABSOLUTELY AND I THINK THAT
IT IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IN
CALIFORNIA TO ALSO FOCUS ON THE
SUPPLIES PIECE- AS I MENTIONED
IN MY REMARKS ABOUT THREE
QUARTERS OF CALIFORNIA
NEIGHBORHOODS HAVE ALMOST NO
LENDING TO BLACK FAMILIES
WHATSOEVER. AND EXCLUSIONARY
ZONING PRACTICES THAT NOT ONLY
DICTATE ONLY SINGLE FAMILY
ZONING BUT THAT ALSO DICTATE OF
MINIMUM LOT SIZES OR- SORT OF
SCHOOL DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS
AROUND SETBACKS ANOTHER ZONING
REQUIREMENTS REALLY LIMITS WHAT
KIND OF STOCK IS BUILT AND THE
AFFORDABILITY OF THAT STOCK-
AND SO I THINK- EFFORTS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS MADE TO
INCREASE THE SUPPLY OF HOUSING.
TO REDUCE EXCLUSIONARY ZONING
PRACTICES ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
PARTS OF THE PUZZLE I THINK
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO.
IMPLEMENT AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THOSE OWNING REFORMS IN A WAY
THAT'S NOT EXTRACTED SO THAT IT
DOESN'T BECOME ANOTHER WAY OF-
SORT OF SPECULATIVE CAPITAL
COMING INTO NEIGHBORHOODS AND
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THAT ZONING
AND CAUSING. ADDITIONAL
CONCERNS AROUND DISPLACEMENTS.
YEAH IN ADDITION TO- CAROLINE
DESCRIBED- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WHILE WE HAVE
THESE THAT THE PLANNING
REGULATIONS ARE ARE OFTEN DONE
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IT'S
IMPORTANT TO- TO CREATE AN
ALMOST. EVEN FOR EQUAL PLAYING
FIELD ACROSS DIFFERENT REGION
THE COMMUNITIES BECAUSE WE
OFTEN SEE THAT EVEN THOUGH
THERE MIGHT BE AN INCREASE IN
SUPPLY- A LOT OF THE- POOR
QUALITY HOUSING IS MORE LIKELY
TO DEVELOP IN. MINORITY
COMMUNITIES AND SO WE HAVE TO
FIND WAYS TO NOT ONLY PRODUCE
MORE HOUSING- BUT TO BE HONEST-BETTER QUALITY HOUSING. WHAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND SO
EVEN THOUGH WE MAY WANT TO
DEGRADE OUR INCREASED
PRODUCTION. BY THE BY I'M SO
NEEDS- WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO AT
TO PROVIDE A SUPPORT COMMUNITY
SO THAT SO THAT STARTING
COMMUNITIES DONNA SAID
ESSENTIALLY OPT OUT OF THE-
REQUIREMENTS. AT THE STATE
LEVEL. THE ANSWERS TO THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE A COUPLE OF
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS MYSELF. I
KNOW WHO. RECENTLY THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF ATTENTION TO RACIAL
BIAS IN THE HOME APPRAISAL
PROCESS- FOR EXAMPLE EXAMPLES
OF. BLACK ON HOMES BEING
APPRAISED AT LOWER VALUES
COMPARED TO WHITE OWNED
PROPERTIES- WANTED TO ASK IF
ANY OF YOU HAVE PERSPECTIVES ON
POLICIES THAT WE SHOULD
CONSIDER. TO ENSURE THAT
APPRAISALS ARE FAIR AND FREE OF
BIAS. SURE WHAT WE KNOW THAT-
APPRAISAL BIAS IS ACTUALLY A
VIOLATION OF STATE AND FEDERAL
FAIR LENDING LAWS- BUT AS YOU
MENTIONED THERE IS A GROWING
BODY OF RESEARCH THAT
DEMONSTRATES. THAT APPRAISAL
DISCRIMINATION IS A SYSTEMIC
ISSUE- AND SO WE REALLY HAVE TO
ADDRESS THE VALUATION OF HOMES
TO COMMUNITIES OF COLOR- HOMES
THAT ARE THAT ARE OWNED BY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IT'S
CRITICAL TO CONSIDER ALL OF THE
CHANGES IN THE APPRAISAL
BUSINESS MODEL. INCLUDING THE
INCREASED USE OF THE AUTOMATED
VALUATION MODELS WITH AN EQUITY
LENS- SO THERE SHOULD BE A
ROBUST REVIEW OF FEDERAL
PRISONS STANDARDS. INCLUDING
ETHICS STANDARDS INCREASE
TRAINING OR UNCONSCIOUS BIAS
FOR APPRAISERS AND EXPANDED
INITIATIVES TO BRING MORE
PRAISES OF COLOR INTO THE
FIELD- WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE
USE OF SALES COMPARISONS IN
NEIGHBORHOODS CARRIES A LEGACY
OF REDLINING INTO THE PRESENT.
AND ALLOW ALSO STARKLY
UNDERVALUED APPRAISALS TO
INFLUENCE CURRENT VALUES. OF
THE APPRAISAL INDUSTRY SHOULD
CONTINUE TO EXPLORE MORE
MODELS- THAT ARE MORE EQUITABLE
ALTERNATIVES. TO WHAT IS
CURRENTLY BEING USED. OTHER
PERSPECTIVE. MAYBE OUT OF
FOLLOW UP TO THAT QUESTION YOU
REFERRED TO- WHAT I UNDERSTAND
IS SORT OF AN INCREASING USE OF
ALGORITHMS AND ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES ARE IN THE FIELD
WHICH MANY WONDERED IF THEY
ARE- SOMEHOW CONTRIBUTING TO
RACIAL DISPARITIES AND OTHER
ALSO QUESTIONS AROUND
CONVENTIONAL CREDIT SCORES AND
HOW THOSE NUMBERS ARE PUT
TOGETHER WONDERING IF YOUR
PERSPECTIVE ON. THE USE OF
THESE ALGORITHMS AND
TECHNOLOGIES AND HOW CAN WE
ENSURE THAT- THEY THEY DON'T
LEAD TO RACIAL DISPARITIES.
SURE I'M SO TO THAT I THINK
THAT WE SHOULD BE VIGILANT
ABOUT ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
AND MACHINE LEARNING MODELS.
CONSIDER THE WAYS IN WHICH THEY
ARE ACTUALLY CONTRIBUTING TO
UNJUSTIFIED OUTCOMES IN CREDIT
DECISIONS ACROSS THE BOARD OF
AND A LOT OF TIMES IT GOES
WITHOUT DETECTION- WE FULLY
BELIEVE THAT THE REGULATORY
AGENCIES SHOUL ACTUALLY BE
CAREFUL NOT TO PUT FORWARD.
GUIDANCE THAT SUGGESTS SUPPORT
FOR INNOVATIVE MODELS OF
TECHNOLOGY WITHOUT ACCOMPANYING
THAT WITH A FAIR LENDING
INQUIRY- A LOT OF TIMES THESE
ALGORITHMIC MODELS ARE BLACK
BOXES. THAT ARE ABLE TO FORM
PREDICTIONS AND DECISIONS IN A
WAY THAT- ARE NOT ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE THE REASONS FOR WHY
THEY MADE THOSE DECISIONS AND
SO CONSUMERS HAVE NO WAY. OF
KNOWING WHAT DATA HAS BEEN FED
INTO THE MODELS AND WHICH
FACTORS THOSE ALGORITHMS ARE
USING A DECISION MAKING AND
INTO THEIR DETERMINATION.
WHETHER THERE ARE PROTECTED
CLASSES AND WHETHER THE
ALGORITHM HAS DENIED CREDIT
BASED ON A RHODIA'S OR BIASED
DATA- WE KNOW THAT A. I. HAS
BEEN AN ELDER THIS IS ACTUALLY
BEEN EXPOSED AS PROBLEMATIC IN
AREAS. INCLUDING EMPLOYMENT AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE- AND SO I
THINK THAT RATHER THAN
SHIELDING ALGORITHMS FROM
EXAMINATION- WE REALLY NEED TO
UP TO AUDIT THEM AND TO AUTUMN
SO AUDIT THESE ALGORITHMIC
SYSTEMS. AND IT'S CRITICAL THAT
WE DO NOT PERMIT THESE MODELS
TO BY PASS FAIR LENDING
SCRUTINY SO THAT WE CAN REALLY
SEE WHAT THE OUTCOMES ARE-
BASED ON ON NEWER TECHNOLOGY.
THANK VERY MUCH AND OUR-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BECAUSE FEW
QUESTION. THANK YOU THE TO BOTH
CHAIRMAN'S FOR PULL THIS TO I
SAID I BOTH CAN SO IT'S REALLY
MY SWEETS HERE- WHAT MICHAEL OF
ALL SET A- VERY CAN ABOUT THE
EQUITY THAT FACE. OUR
COMMUNITIES PARTICULAR ON
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND I SEE TO MY
COMMUNITY VERY DIVERSE
COMMUNITY. AND THE COMMUNITY OF
COLOR ARE CONSISTENTLY I'M
GETTING FURTHER AND FURTHER
BEHIND IN TERMS OF BEING ABLE
TO PROCURE AND BUY HOMES WHICH
IS HOW WE BUILD WEALTH IN THIS
COUNTRY- SO IT'S AN ISSUE AYE
AYE CARE TREMENDOUSLY ABOUT. I
WAS CURIOUS IF ANY THE
PANELISTS COULD ALSO SHARE
GIVEN WHAT IS HAPPENED WITH
COVERT NINETEEN THE IMPACT
ECONOMICALLY ON SOME OF THESE
COMMUNITIES AND CAN WE- GET A
HOLD OF THIS THIS CRISIS HAS
CREATED AND HOW FAR ARE WE
BEHIND GIVEN WHAT HAS HAPPENED
WITH THE PANDEMIC IN TERMS OF.
ACQUIRING MORE HOME
HOMEOWNERSHIP PERSONALLY FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HAVE BEEN
HARDEST HIT BALL FROM A HEALTH
PERSPECTIVE. AND FINANCIALLY
BECAUSE OF THE CRISIS. I THINK
THE IMPACT ON HISPANIC ASIAN
AND BLACK COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
NINETEEN IS GOING TO BE A LONG
STANDING. I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS WE LEARNED FROM THE LAST
RECESSION IS THAT. IF WE WAIT
TO SEE THE PROBLEM WE'RE GOING
TO BE TOO LATE. AND SO IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE THINK
BOLDLY NOW ABOUT HOW TO KEEP
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES. UP WE
KNOW THAT- DELINQUENCIES AROUND
MORTGAGES FOR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR RIGHT NOW ARE ABOUT. 45%
HIGHER THAN FOR NON HISPANIC
WHITES. I THINK THE QUESTION IS
HOW LONG HAVE THEY BEEN I'M
UNEMPLOYED HOW LONG HAD THEY
NOT HAD ACCESS TO INCOME. AND
HOW MUCH DEBT ARE THEY
RECRUITING. BECAUSE INEXPENSIVE
MARKET LIKE CALIFORNIA. IF YOU
HAVE A CRUDE FOUR SIX EIGHT A
YEAR OF ARREARS IN MORTGAGE
DEBT. IT'S GONNA BE VERY HARD
TO OVERCOME THAT. AND IT'S
GONNA LIVER LIMIT OTHER LIFE
CHANCES AND SO. ON AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
REMARKS. THINKING ABOUT A
RESCUE FUNDS TO THAT FAMILIES
DON'T NECESSARILY NEED TO SELL
THEIR HOMES UNDER INVOLUNTARY
CIRCUMSTANCES- AND OR- MAKING
SURE THAT THE- DEBT ISN'T. USED
IN. ARE ARE TAKEN AT. YOUR-
THERE ISN'T SORT OF UP.
RESPONSE TO THAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR RACIAL. YEAH
GOING OFF CAROLINE'S POINT I
THINK THAT ANOTHER ONE OF THE-
SMALL ADVANTAGES COMPARED TO
THE GREAT RECESSION IS THAT
HOME VALUES CONTINUE TO
INCREASE AND SO A LOT OF THESE
FAMILIES THAT ARE- THAT- THAT
ARE VERY PICKY LIKE INVARIANTS
IS SENSITIVE AND PRECARIOUS
FINANCIAL SITUATIONS ARE
PROBABLY GONNA BE OOKING
TOWARDS THE REFINANCE MARKET.
AND SO I THINK GOING FORWARD WE
HAVE TO EXAMINE THE TYPES OF
PRODUCTS THAT THE STATE. AND
LOCAL- BANKING FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS CAN PROVIDE TO
THOSE FAMILIES. THAT ARE
NECESSARILY WHAT WE'RE
ACCUSTOMED TO IN THE PER IN THE
PAST BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO SEE
LARGE VOLUMES OF THESE FAMILIES
IF THEY DO WINDING STAY IN
THEIR HOMES TO KICK TO CATCH UP
ESSENTIALLY BASED OFF OF THE
FINANCIAL SITUATION THAN THE
FINANCIAL BURDENS OF THE
COPING. THEY'RE GOING TO LOOK
TO THE REFINANCE MARKET TO STAY
IN THEIR HOMES AND TO OBTAIN
SOME OF THE EQUITY THAT THEY'VE
BEEN ABLE TO ACQUIRE SO I THINK
LOOKING FOR DIFFERENT WAYS TO
ALLOW THESE FAMILIES TO ACCESS
SOME OF THAT EQUITIES IT IS AN
ADVANTAGE COMPARED TO THE GREAT
RECESSION. THAT WE SAW. A TEN
OR FIFTEEN YEARS AGO. BUT THE-
WHERE THOSE PREDATORY PRACTICES
MIGHT EMERGE RIGHT BECAUSE WE
DEFINITELY SAW IN THE SUBPRIME
GROOM. THE FIRST RESPONSE WAS
OR THE FIRST PROBLEM WAS
REFINANCE PRODUCTS IN LOW
INCOME AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
SO. AT OVERSIGHT REGULATION
THERE IS A REALLY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANNOUNCER
ANY FINAL QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M GOING TO
ASK THE PANELISTS IF YOU WANNA
MAKE ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
VERTICALLY RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
YOU HAVE FOR US ON THIS AND ONE
THING I'LL ALSO ASK IS- YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY EVERY PART OF
THE STATE IS A BIT DIFFERENT- I
ALONG WITH THE NUMBER OF
MEMBERS ON THIS- COMMITTEE.
REPRESENT HIGH COST REGIONS IN
THE BAY AREA AND WONDERING.
GENERALLY DO HAVE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU HOPE
TO LEAVE WITH US AND- DO THESE
STRATEGIES LOOK. DIFFERENT FOR
HIGH COST REGIONS LIKE THE BAY
AREA. AND HAPPY FOR ANYONE TO
JUMP IN OR- WE CAN MOVE TO THE
NEXT PANEL. OKAY YOUR FIRST HE
FIRST SURE I'M JUST GOING TO
SAY THAT WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT SERVICERS ARE
COMMUNICATING TO HOMEOWNERS
TODAY ALL AVAILABLE OPTIONS
THAT THEY HAVE TO STAY IN THEIR
HOMES AND TO AVOID FORECLOSURE
WE KNOW THAT AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL- IT AND OTHER ADVOCATES
HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR CONGRESS
TO EXTEND THE PROTECTIONS THAT
THE FEDERAL HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY AND THE FEDERAL HOUSING
ADMINISTRATION- HAVE PROVIDED
TO PRIVATELY HELD MORTGAGES AS
WELL AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT
PRIVATE LOANS SHOULD ADOPT A
FORECLOSURE MORATORIUM AND
FORBEARANCE POLICIES OFFERED BY
DGSE OR FHA AS WELL AS TO MERIT
THE FEDERALLY BACKED LOANS IN
PROVIDING CLUES FOR BAND
SOLUTIONS. THEY DO NOT INCREASE
BORROWERS MONTHLY PAYMENTS SO
TO THE EXTENT THAT CALIFORNIA
CAN ENSURE THAT SERVICERS ARE
COMMUNICATING ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION TO FARMERS- WE
THINK THAT THAT'S REALLY
CRITICAL AND IT'S ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT THE FARMERS
CONSIDERED HARD TO REACH LIKE
THOSE AND RURAL COMMUNITIES AND
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
FARMERS ARE RECEIVING TIMELY
AND ACCURATE INFORMATION BUT I
WOULD SAY- IN ADDITION TO THIS
POLICYMAKERS MUST ALSO REALLY
SUPPORT THE WORK OF HOUSING
COUNSELING AGENCIES WHICH ARE
ON THE FRONT LINES FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES OFTENTIMES THE
FIRST CALL- WILL GO TO A
HOUSING COUNSELING AGENCY WHEN
A WHEN A HOMEOWNERS IN DISTRESS
WHAT DO SERVICERS ARE NOT
HOUSING HOUSING AGENCIES- AND
SO. THESE THESE ORGANIZATIONS
WILL PLAY AN INTEGRAL ROLE IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE US
DEPARTMENT TREASURIES HOMEOWNER
ASSISTANCE FUND THAT WAS
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED- AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THE STATE SHOULD
BE READY TO WORK WITH TREASURY
AND ALL PROFITS IN CALIFORNIA
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS AN
INFECTED AND EFFECTIVE AND
EQUITABLE- DELIVERY OF THE
PROGRAM AND WE HAVE OPPORTUNITY
TO INCREASE RESOURCES FROM THE
STATE TO SUPPLEMENT THE FEDERAL
HOUSING COUNSELING AGENCY FUNDS
WE. SHOULD ACT ON THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL. I WOULD
JUST ANSWER. THAT ONE. NAY TO
BE OF THE- BUT ALSO MAY SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE CAN PASS AMONG
DRIVEN INSTITUTIONS. TO
PURCHASE PROPERTIES THAT ARE
BEING FLIPPED THAT ARE BEING
SOLD THAT ARE IN FORECLOSURE SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANOTHER WAVE
OF SPECULATIVE CAPITAL HITTING.
LOW INCOME AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. AND FINALLY I THINK OF
FOR ME I THINK ONE OF THE
POINTS I KNOW THIS IS A FOCUS
ON HOMEOWNERSHIP. ONE OF THE
POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS IS ALSO UP
TO THINK ABOUT THE
AFFORDABILITY ON THE RENTAL
SIDE AND TO CONSIDER THE TYPES
OF- AMENITIES AND THE RESOURCES
THAT WERE NOT PROVIDING. TO THE
RENTAL SIDE THAT ARE ALSO
EXACERBATING THE DIFFERENCES IN
HOMEOWNERSHIP RATES ACROSS
THESE ETHNO RACIAL COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ON BEHALF OF
OUR TWO COMMITTEES REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR EXPERTISE IN
THE ONGOING CONVERSATION. NOW
THIS IS SOMETHING OF A GREAT
INTEREST I KNOW TO MANY OF US
AND APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTS.
AND WITH THAT I'M GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO- MY FULL CHAIR TO.
MODERATE THE NEXT PANEL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WE ARE NOT
GOING TO TURN TO OUR PANEL ON
FIGHTING FIGHTING
DISCRIMINATION AND DISPARATE
OUTCOMES AND RENTAL HOUSING. SO
OUR FIRST WITNESS IS PROFESSOR
TIM THOMAS RESEARCH DIRECTOR AT
THE URBAN DISPLACEMENT PROJECT
UC BERKELEY. WELCOME PROFESSOR
THOMAS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IT'S A REAL PLEASURE TO BE HERE
I HAVE A SHORT PRESENTATION
THAT I COULD HOPEFULLY SHOW TO
YOU. PLEASE LET ME KNOW IF
THERE'S ANY ERRORS OR ANY
ISSUES- MY NAME'S TIM THOMAS
AND I AM THE RESEARCH DIRECTOR
FOR THE URBAN DISPLACEMENT
PROJECT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY- ANDS I
WOULD LIKE TO TALK TO YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN CALIFORNIA
RENTERS- BY AND LARGE WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THIS IDEA OF
HOUSING STABILITY IT'S ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT COMPONENTS
TO ENSURING THAT HOUSEHOLDS.
CAN IMPROVE THEIR OUTCOMES WE
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT MOBILITY
AND ECONOMIC STATUS SO WE CAN
THINK ABOUT. MOBILITY IN TERMS
OF- ON THE X. AXIS HERE THIS
GRAPH WE CAN SEE THAT ECONOMIC
STATUS FROM THE LEFT HAND SIDE
LOW INCOME TO THE RIGHT HAND
SIDE IS HIGH INCOME. IN THE Y.
AXIS SHOWS MOBILITY AS YOU CAN
SEE THERE'S A LOT OF FOLKS THAT
ARE- UNFORCED OR ABLE TO MOVE
TO LOCATIONS WHEREVER THEY'D
LIKE BASED ON THEIR INCOME THEY
USUALLY MOVE TO. AREAS WITH
BETTER JOBS- ECONOMIC
IMPROVEMENTS AND ALSO IMPROVE
THEIR NETWORKS MIDDLE INCOME
FOLKS HAVE LESS MOBILITY AND ON
THE FAR LEFT WE HAVE A LOT OF
FOLKS WHO HAVE FORCED MOBILITY
THIS IS WHERE A LOT OF RENTERS.
FALL IN LINE WE KNOW A LOT
ABOUT THE RIGHT TWO THIRDS BUT
WE KNOW VERY LITTLE ABOUT THE
LEFT- ORDER A FORCED MOBILE
HOUSEHOLDS AND SO BE- OBJECTIVE
OF- THE URBAN DISPLACEMENT
PROJECT IS TO UNDERSTAND HOW.
WHO IS INSIDE THIS GROUP THAT
IS FORCED TO MOVE IN OTHER
WORDS UNABLE TO ACHIEVE STABLE
HOUSING AND A LOT OF TIMES THIS
IS A LOT OF RENTERS THESE ARE
FOLKS THAT ARE FACING
INCREASING REPS AS WELL AS A
FICTION. NOW IN TERMS OF
EVICTION WE CAN KIND OF SEE
THAT THERE'S SEVERAL FACTORS
THAT PLAY A ROLE IN TO IT AT
THE HOUSEHOLD LEVEL AT THE
BOTTOM THERE'S A TRIANGLE OF
INCREASING RENT. IMPACTED WITH
INADEQUATE WELFARE AND HOUSING
BURDEN. WE'RE ON TOP OF IT HAVE-
MARKET ECONOMIC. SEGREGATION
NEIGHBORHOOD CHANGE. THAT IS
IMPACTING THE ABILITY OF
HOUSEHOLDS TO BE ABLE TO STAY
IN THEIR HOME. AND BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN STABLE HOUSING. BUT
BEFORE WE GET INTO THIS IDEA OF
WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW ON
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING AND
RENTING WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
THE HISTORY AND WHICH SEPARATED
DIFFERENT RACIAL GROUPS INTO
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES AND THIS
STARTS FROM THE POST ANTEBELLUM
CIVIL WAR. AROUND WHAT MOST
SCHOLARS CALLED THE BIRTH OF
THE GHETTO FROM EIGHTEEN NINETY
NINETEEN FORTY. FROM THE
NINETEEN TENDS TO THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES THERE WAS THIS PERIOD
OF THE GREAT MIGRATION OF BLACK
HOUSEHOLDS MOVING FROM JIM CROW
SOUTH TO THE NORTH AND TO THE
WEST. BUT AS THEY ENTERED INTO
THESE NEW CITIES THERE WAS A
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION IN TERMS
OF HOUSING AS WELL AS EQUITY I
WON'T BELABOR THIS TOO MUCH WE
ALL HEARD ABOUT REDLINING AND
KNOW A LOT ABOUT IT. THAT
BATES- DENIED ACCESS TO FOLKS
WHO LIVED IN THESE PLACES
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THAT THE
PATTERNS THAT WERE ESTABLISHED
IN THE EARLY NINETEEN HUNDREDS
EXISTS TODAY IN TERMS OF RACIAL
SEGREGATION FOR EXAMPLE YOU CAN
SEE ON THE TOP THE REDLINING
MAP. SOMEWHAT MIRRORS A LITTLE
BIT OF THE RACIAL SEGREGATION
DISTRIBUTION OF HOUSEHOLDS IN
THE LA AREA. AROUND NINETEEN
FORTY TWO- NINETEEN SEVENTY
THERE WAS CONTINUED WHAT WAS
CALLED COLLECTIVE ACTION BREAK
RACISM WHICH INVOLVED A LOT OF-
COVENANTS HOUSING COVENANTS
THAT PREVENTED- BLACK
INDIGENOUS- ASIAN LATIN ACTS
HOUSEHOLDS OF COLOR. TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE INTO CERTAIN SPACES
DENYING THEM ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITIES. WHAT THIS
ULTIMATELY DID- IT LED TO
ANOTHER PERIOD OF DECENTRALIZE
RACISM WHERE THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ACT TRIED TO EQUATE MORE TRIED
IMPROVE THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
DISMANTLING WITH LEGAL
SEGREGATION AND DISCRIMINATION.
BUT THE LASTING EFFECTS OF
REDLINING BLOCKBUSTING
DISCRIMINATION LED TO AN
INCREASE IN CONCENTRATED
POVERTY. AND ALSO- CAN
MIGRATION OF MIDDLE CLASS-
BLACK HOUSEHOLDS INTO THE
SUBURBS WHITE FLIGHT AVOIDING.
THOSE NEW NEIGHBORS THAT THEY
WERE SEEING. NOW WHAT THIS DID
AS ADULTS OF IMPACTED THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR HOUSEHOLDS OF
COLOR TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
GROWTH OF THE MIDDLE CLASS OVER
THE NINETEEN HUNDREDS AS YOU
CAN SEE FROM 1-963-220-0016 ON
THIS GRAPH. THE WEALTH GAP
GREATLY INCREASE THIS IS
LARGELY DUE TO THE DENIAL OF
ACCESS TO OWNING A HOME. AND
FORCING HOUSEHOLDS OF COLOR TO
PARTICULARLY- BLACK AND WHITE
NECKS AND HISPANIC HOUSEHOLDS
TO RENT AT AVERAGES- WELL BELOW
WHAT WHITES- HOUSEHOLDS ARE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE. IN CALIFORNIA
THERE'S A HUGE GAP IN TERMS OF
WHO RENTS AND WHO OWNS WHITE-
HOUSEHOLDS ABOUT 63% OF THEM IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA OMERS
37% OF THEM RENTS. ASIAN
HOUSEHOLDS ARE AT 59% OWNERSHIP
41% RENTING LATINO FORTY FOUR
TO FIFTY SIX RENTING. BLACK
HOUSEHOLDS IN PARTICULAR ONLY
35% RENTS WHERE AS A 65% I'M
SORRY 35% OWN 65% RENTS. BOB
THIS LEADS TO AN ISSUE WHERE AS
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE CHANGING IT'S
IMPACTING THE MOBILITY AND
STABILITY OF HOUSEHOLDS
PARTICULARLY BLACK HOUSEHOLDS
IN LENEXA HOUSEHOLDS. WHERE
THE- POST NINETEEN NINETY PECAN
CRIME CONCENTRATED POVERTY
BECAUSE OF SEGREGATION. LED TO
A LOT OF MARKET DIVESTMENT
HOWEVER THE BACK TO THE CITY
MOVEMENT OR GENTRIFICATION AS
WE WELL KNOW IT. LED TO A LOT
OF WHITE HOUSEHOLDS BEING UP TO
TEN LOANS AND PREVIOUSLY
SEGREGATED URBAN SPACES. WHAT
IS LED TO IS. THOSE SAME
REDLINING MAPS WE SEE 87% IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA FOR
EXAMPLE 87% OF REDLINED
NEIGHBORHOODS GENTRIFIED OVER
THAT PERIOD OF TIME. AND AS YOU
CAN SEE THERE'S A QUITE A BIT
OF VARIATION IN TERMS OF
AFFORDABILITY IN TERMS OF WHO
CAN ACTUALLY AFFORD HOME OR NOT
THIS GRAPH SHOWS THE- TO A ON A
ONE BEDROOM- COST IN EACH OF
THE COUNTIES WHERE THERE'S OVER
A THOUSAND RENTERS IN THE LEFT
HAND SIDE IS THE- RENTS. THAT
IS- FOR THESE FOR MARKET RENT
AREAS ON THE RIGHT HAND SIDE
SHOWS THE AMOUNT OF MONEY YOU
HAVE TO EARN. TO BE ABLE TO
AFFORD OR IN OTHER WORDS AVOID
RENT BIRD. NOW ACROSS ALL THESE
COUNTIES WE CAN SEE THAT WHITE
HOUSEHOLDS IN PARTICULAR WELL
ABOVE. THAT RENT BURDENED
THRESHOLD. BUT PARTICULARLY
AROUND AREAS ON THE FAR RIGHT
HAND SIDE LIKE SAN FRANCISCO
SAN MATTEO- SANTA CLARA THOSE
ARE VERY HIGH INCOMES. WE LOOK
AT ASIAN HOUSEHOLDS THEY WERE
ABLE TO FARE PRETTY WELL AND
THEY'RE ABLE TO ACHIEVE-
INCOMES ABOVE THE RENT BURDEN.
THRESHOLD WHAT WE LOOK AT LIVE
NEXT HOUSEHOLDS- IN PARTICULAR
WE'RE STARTING TO SEE THAT
THEIR MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME
OVER IN OTHER WORDS HALF OF THE
POPULATION. IS FALLING AWAY
BELOW- THE RENT BURDEN AREA
UNABLE TO AFFORD SOMETHING
SPACES IN A PARTICULAR BLACK
HOUSEHOLDS ARE FALLING WELL
BELOW. THE AREA OF RENT BURDEN
THAT- PREVENTS THEM FROM BEING
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE. WORK BE
ABLE TO STAY IN PLACE- THE PAST
FEW YEARS WE'VE SEEN A MASSIVE
DECLINE IN MOST URBAN. WHICH IS
FORCED TO DISPLACEMENT. THROUGH
RISING HOUSING COSTS AND
EVICTION INTO THE SUBURBS
UNFORTUNATELY POVERTY AND ALSO
UNEMPLOYMENT. AND LOWER
EDUCATION HAS BEEN INCREASING
IN THE SUBURBS AS WELL AS WELL
AS THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
DECLINE. NOW IN TERMS OF
EVICTIONS CURRENTLY IN THE
PANDEMIC WE'RE STILL SEEING A
VERY HUGE RATE OF A FICTIONAL
MONTHS BLACK HOUSEHOLD TO
PROTECT LOOK PARTICULARLY IN
AREAS WHERE THERE LOWER LOCAL
MORATORIUMS ARE PROTECTIONS. BY
LARGE BLACK HOUSEHOLDS ARE TWO
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO FACE
EVICTION DURING THE PANDEMIC.
BLACK WOMEN IN PARTICULAR ARE
FACING UP TO FIVE TO SEVEN
TIMES MORE THAN WHITE MEN AND
WOMEN IN TERMS OF EVICTION
FORCING THEM INTO DISPLACEMENT.
NOW QUICKLY I'LL END WITH THIS
POLICY RECOMMENDATION OF WHAT
WE GET THE URBAN DISPLACEMENT
PROJECT CALLED THE THREE PIECE
TARA PROTECTIONS WHICH INVOLVED
JUST BECAUSE LEGAL
REPRESENTATION EVICTIONS. ALSO
RENTAL SINCE ASSISTANCE WE
ALSO- PROMOTE PROTECTING
EXISTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WHICH INCLUDES INCLUSIONARY
ZONING RENT CONTROL IDENTIFYING
HOUSING VULNERABILITY
INSENSITIVE COMMUNITIES. AND
ALSO PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND REMOVING SINGLE
FAMILY ZONING WITHOUT ALL THE-
SETTLEMENT TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
INSIGHTFUL PRESENTATION WE WILL
NOW HEAR FROM MERIAL BLOCK
STAFF ATTORNEY NATIONAL HOUSING
LAW PROJECT WELCOME THE FOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- I JUST SHARE
MY SCREEN. THAT'S. ARE YOU ABLE
TO SEE MY SCREEN. YES OKAY
WONDERFUL SO BE THINKING ON
NUISANCE AND CRIME FREE
ORDINANCES TODAY- ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. A NUISANCE IN CRIME
FOR YOU PROPERTY ORDINANCES ARE
BEING USED TO EXCLUDE AN EFFECT
BLACK BUT NEXT AND OTHER PEOPLE
OF COLOR FROM RENTAL HOUSING.
NATIONALLY THERE ARE AN
ESTIMATED TWO THOUSAND
MUNICIPALITIES WHEN YOU SINCE
AND CRIME FREE ORDINANCES AND
IN CALIFORNIA THERE ARE AT
LEAST A HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
NUISANCE AND CRIME FREE
ORDINANCES AND PROGRAMS. WHAT A
NUISANCE AND CRIME FREE. THEY
ARE- LOCAL LAWS AND POLICIES
THAT PENALIZE LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS FOR CERTAIN ACTIVITIES
THAT OCCUR AT A GIVEN PROPERTY.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THIS
LIST OF ACTIVITIES THEY'RE
OFTEN VERY BROAD. J. SUBJECTIVE
AND CAN EVEN INCLUDE EVERYDAY
ACTIVITIES. THEY OFTEN ALSO
INCLUDE VIRTUALLY ANY CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY INCLUDING MINOR
NONVIOLENT OFFENSES AND THE
PENALTIES CAN BE EXTREMELY
STRINGENT THEY INCLUDE EVICTION
IMPRISONMENT DAILY FINES- AND
OTHER PENALTIES. TYPICAL
FEATURES A NUISANCE AND CRIME
FREE- ORDINANCES IN PROGRAMS
AGAIN INCLUDE BROADBAND OR
SUBJECTIVE DEFINITIONS OF
NUISANCE AND CRIMINAL ACTIVITY-
REQUIREMENTS THAT LANDLORDS
ABATE THE NUISANCE ACTIVITY
INCLUDING THREE FACTION.
REQUIREMENTS FOR CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND SCREENING FOR
POTENTIAL TENANTS- REQUIREMENTS
ATTENDANCE AND VERY ONEROUS
COUNTRY LEASE AGENDA AND
VIRTUALLY NO DUE PROCESS RIGHTS
FOR TENANTS IN THIS PROCESS.
THERE ARE OTHER SOURCES A
NUISANCE AND CRIME FREE FOR-
ENFORCEMENT AGAINST TENANTS IN
CALIFORNIA ASIDE FROM THESE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE NUISANCE
AND CRIME FREE ORDINANCES AND
PROGRAMS THESE INCLUDE THE
STATE- UNLAWFUL DETAINER PILOT
PROGRAM. THIS IS A CITY
ATTORNEY INITIATED NEW SENSE OF
ACTION PROGRAM- ANTICIPATING.
CITIES INCLUDE LOS ANGELES LONG
BEACH OAKLAND AND SACRAMENTO-
AND THIS IS SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
CITY ATTORNEYS GENERALLY DON'T
HAVE STANDING TO BRING OF
ACTION CASES BUT THIS- PROGRAM-
EXPANDS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THESE TYPES OF NUISANCE
EVICTIONS. IN ADDITION FOR
CALIFORNIA DETAINER STATUTE
SPECIFICALLY CCP ELEVEN SIXTY
ONE FOR WHICH IS A NEW SIM
GROUND EVICTION. ALSO PROVIDE
SIMILAR SIMILARLY BROAD GROUND-
BY WHICH TENANTS CAN BE A-
BASED ON A VERY POORLY DEFINED-
DEFINITION OF NEWS. AND TO MAKE
MATTERS WORSE TENANTS CAN BE
EVICTED WITH ONLY THREE DAYS
NOTICE AND HAVE NO RIGHT TO
REMEDY THE ALLOCATION.
UNSURPRISINGLY THESE NUISANCE
AND CRIME FREE POLICIES HAVE A
DISPARATE IMPACT ON BY PART
TIME. THEY OFF APPROVED IN
RESPONSE TO QUOTE UNQUOTE
DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGE OR AN
INCREASE IN BY PRODUCT
RESIDENTS MOVING INTO AN AREA-
THE L. A. TIMES COMPLETED A
ANALYSIS- AND PUBLISH THIS IN
AN ARTICLE LATE LAST YEAR. AND
THEY FOUND THAT 85% OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES WITH THE
LARGEST INCREASES IN BLACK
POPULATION SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE APPROVED CRIME FREE
HOUSING POLICIES. THAT
ENCOURAGE ADDICTION- AND
ANOTHER EXAMPLE- THIS IS THE
CITY OF HYSTERIA WHICH HAS-
FAST A NUISANCE AND CRIME FREE
PROPERTY ORDINANCE IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN- AND
STATEMENTS WERE MADE BY CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS AND OTHERS IN
THEIR OFFICIAL CAPACITY WHAT AT
THE TIME THAT THIS WAS PASSED-
THAT- INDICATED A RACIALLY
DISCRIMINATORY MOTIVATION FOR
PASSING THE LOT IT WAS PASSED
IN RESPONSE TO A QUOTE UNQUOTE
DEMOGRAPHICALLY PROBLEM AND IT
THERE IS ALSO EVIDENCE THAT IT
WAS DISPROPORTIONATELY ENFORCED
AGAINST BLACK AND LYFT NEXT
TENANTS. AND AS A RESULT ABOUT
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THE U.
S. DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SUED
THE CITY OF THIS AREA AS WELL
AS A SAMBAR DINO COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT ON THE
GROUNDS THAT THEIR FREE HOUSING-
AGAINST BLACK AND MONEX RENTERS
AND THIS CASE IS STILL ONGOING-
THE CALIFORNIA UNLAWFUL
DETAINER PILOT PROGRAM HAS.
ALSO SHOWN TO BE-
DISPROPORTIONATELY ENFORCED
AGAINST- BLACK AND NOT NEXT AND
OTHER TENANTS AS WELL AS OTHER
PEOPLE OF COLOR- AND LA TIMES
ANALYSIS- LOOKING AT RECORDS
FROM TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN TO
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. SO THAT
NEARLY 80% OF THE TENANTS
TARGETED PROTECTION UNDER THIS
PROGRAM WHERE BLACK LOT NEXT
ANOTHER TENANTS OF COLOR. I
NEED- BUT TENANTS BASED
EVICTION CASE OF EXACT TWICE
THEY'RE SURE THE CITY'S OUR POP-
CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN SOME
IMPORTANT FIRST STEPS IN TRYING
TO MITIGATE THAT TIME DOING.
IMPACTS OF NUISANCE AND CRIME
FREE ORDINANCES PROGRAMS-
RECENTLY- THERE IS AT THE HEART
REGULATION THAT WAS PASSED OUT-
PENALTIES AGAINST AND TENANTS
ON BROAD DEFINITIONS OF
NUISANCE ACTIVITIES- SO THIS IS
A GREAT FIRST STEP AND IN
ADDITION- CALIFORNIA AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTEEN. WHICH WAS
CHAMPIONED BY SOME REMEMBER TO
THE RIGHT TO SAFE HOME ACT ALSO
PROTECTED SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE VICTIMS OF CRIME AND
OTHER INDIVIDUALS IN EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS FROM- BEING AFFECTED
FOR CALLING THE POLICE. OR
OTHER EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE.
HOWEVER MORE- PROTECTIONS ARE
NEEDED TO COMBAT THIS PROBLEM
I'M SURE SOME POTENTIAL POLICY
SOLUTIONS TERMINATING THE
UNLAWFUL DETAINER PILOT PROGRAM
OF COURSE THIS IS SLATED TO
SUNSET TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND
IT SHOULD ABSOLUTELY BE ADDED
AT THAT POINT. IF NOT BEFORE-
ELIMINATES OR NARROW CCP ELEVEN
SIXTY ONE TOWARD THE NUISANCE
FOR EVICTION TO MORE DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS AND ELIMINATE-
BROAD BASED- ADDICTION GROUNDS
AGAINST TENANTS. AND
CALIFORNIA'S A NUISANCE IN
CRIME FREE HOUSE ORDINANCE AND
PRO. AND ANY POTENTIAL SO THAT-
OUR IDENTIFIED BY DIRECTLY.
TENANTS YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR- FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION AND NOW I
WOULD LIKE TO GO TO OUR FINAL
PANELIST BEFORE WE GO TO Q. AND
A AND THAT'S NEVER MEET GROW
ALL LITIGATION COUNSEL
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WELCOME. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE FOR HAVING
ME TODAY. SO I WANT TO TALK A
BIT ABOUT WHY THESE RACIAL
DISPARITIES MATTER AND HOW THEY
MANIFEST THROUGHOUT THE
LIFECYCLE OF RENTAL HOUSING. SO
FIRST THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREASING AMOUNT OF STUDIES
THAT CONFIRM WHAT I THINK WE
ALL KNOW. INTRINSICALLY WHICH
IS THAT WHERE WE LIVE. MATTERS
FOR ALMOST EVERY PART OF OUR
LIFE. WHERE WE LIVE HAS
CONCRETE OUTCOMES EITHER
POSITIVE OR NEGATIVE ON OUR
MORTALITY RATES ARE MENTAL
HEALTH OUR ABILITY TO
ACCUMULATE WEALTH OUR ABILITY
TO PASS THAT WEALTH LONG
GENERATIONS. AND SO. IF YOU'RE
IN A COMMUNITY THAT HAS A LOT
OF OPPORTUNITY HAS OPEN SPACES
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE BETTER
OUTCOMES AND CONVERSELY YOU'LL
HAVE MORE NEGATIVE OUTCOMES IF
YOU DON'T HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY.
SO WHAT I WANTED TO TALK ABOUT
TWO DIFFERENT CITIES THAT I'VE
WORKED IN ON SYSTEMIC ADVOCACY
ONE OF THOSE COMMUNITIES WAS
WHAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED AN
AREA OF OPPORTUNITY IT'S A CITY
THAT HAD BEEN. HAS HISTORICALLY
BEEN VERY EXCLUSIONARY- IS A
BIT WEALTHIER HAS GOOD SCHOOLS.
HAS HAS GOOD ACTORS TO JOBS
ANOTHER COMMUNITY ONE THAT IS
CONSIDERED A RACIALLY AND
ETHNICALLY CAUGHT CONCENTRATED
AREAS OF POVERTY. SO THE FOR
COMMUNITY EVEN CALLED AREA OF
OCT IS ONE WAY I WAS TO AND
WORK ON PREVENTING THE MASTERS.
OF RESIDENTS WHO HAD LIVED LONG
TERM IN MOTELS IN THE CITY. FOR
DECADES AS WE FOUND OUT THE
CITY HAD STIFLED THE PRODUCTION
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING- THERE'S
SOME PRETTY DISCRIMINATORY
MEANS- AND SO THE RESIDENTS WHO
WERE LOWER INCOME IN IN THAT
CITY MANY OF WHOM ARE LATINO
WERE LIVING LONG TERM BRING
THIS. AS I GOT TO KNOW A NUMBER
OF THESE RESIDENTS I BEGAN TO
FIND PATTERNS LIVING IN A MOTEL
IS NOT CHEAP. IT IS NOT
AFFORDABLE. IT IS OFTEN NOT
ACCESSIBLE. BUT THE REASON THAT
MANY WERE LIVING THERE IS
BECAUSE THE SAME. FORECLOSURE
CRISIS THE SAME SUBPRIME
LENDING THAT AFFECTS BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY HAD
DESTROYED SO MANY OF THEIR
CREDIT HISTORIES. TO SUCH AN
EXTENT THAT THEY HAD NO CHOICE
BUT TO LIVE IN MOTELS BECAUSE
NO TRADITIONAL APARTMENT
COMPLEX WOULD ACCEPT WOULD
ACCEPT THEM AS RENTERS. OTHERS
HAVE CRIMINAL HISTORY. BECAUSE
OF THE SAME MASS INCARCERATION
THAT HAS DEVASTATED BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES. AND THE BILL
AREAS TO SCREENING TENDENCIES
BASED ON CRIMINAL HISTORY ALSO
LEFT THEM WITH NO OTHER CHOICE.
ONE MOTHER THAT I TALKED TO
WHEN I ASKED HER WHY DID SHE
LIVE IN THE CITY INSTEAD OF
MOVING. SHE SAID TO ME WELL MY
SON HAS AUTISM. THIS IS THE
ONLY PLACE THAT I CAN GET A
GOOD INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATION
PLAN FOR. AND I THINK THAT'S
REALLY STUCK WITH ME. WE COULD
WE HAVE CREATED THESE BARRIERS
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE'VE
CREATED BARRIERS ALONG TENANTS
YOU SCREENING. WE'VE HELLO TAX
CONSIDER WHO ARE WE TRYING TO
HOW. AND WHAT OPPORTUNITIES.
EXIST FOR FOLKS THAT WERE
PUSHING PEOPLE INTO A REALLY
PRECARIOUS SITUATION. WHERE
THEY DO SO POTENTIAL EVICTION.
AND ENTERED AND UP INTO BEING
X. IN THE- BEFORE WE WERE ABLE
TO COME TO SOME SOLUTION.
BECAUSE THESE BARRIERS MANIFEST
ALONG. THE PLANNING AND
PRODUCTION SIDE OF RENTAL
HOUSING DID MANIFESTED ACCESS.
EIGHT LEAVE YOUR A SITUATION
WHERE. LANDLORDS CAN HARASS YOU
WITH EACH BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH- ENFORCEMENT OF LAWS
BOTH THE PROTECT TENANTS AND
THAT PREVENT DISCRIMINATION AND
THEN I THINK YOU END UP TO THE
PLACE THE PROFESSOR THOMAS
DISCUSSED- ABOUT THESE SORT OF
MASS DISPLACEMENT OFFENSE AND
RESEGREGATION JUSTICE TO
DIFFERENT NEIGHBORHOODS. THANK
CAN YOU THAT THE- I'M WORK IN.
AS I SAID IS OF RACIALLY ETHNIC
CONS POVERTY. ALL MY INTO LACK
READ. WANTED THE COMMUNITY ARE
I WORK WITH AN L. WOMAN DOES
THE- WHO LIVES WITH MANY
GENERATIONS OF FAMILY. WHICH IT
AT HOME THAT OVER. THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY LIKE TO HELP IMPACT
ESPECIALLY TO THE SPEND DOWN
WE'RE OVERCROWDED MAKES IT AND
TO COURT PARTICULARLY FOR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. BUT THERE'S
A COMMITTEE THAT A BRIEF TO
ENGAGE WITH MEMBERS WHO ARE AT
FOR HELP THAT'S OF TO THEM.
IT'S A- TO THE AND THAT'S
HEALTH- THAT. THE EFFECT OF
TALK- THE TWO SOIL AND AIR THE
THIRD. TO YOU. AND OF THE
COMMUNITY HAS THIS PARTICULAR
COMMUNITY LEAD HAVE LOOKED.
LURING ITS PLANNING FOR THE RE
AND HIGHER HOW. AND OF PLAY FOR
NEEDS OF THOSE WHO ARE DEEPLY
THERE. AND INTO OF THE PA THAT
SORT OF THROUGH THE I THINK ONE
THING THAT YOU SEE. IS THAT IN
BOTH COMMUNITIES. THE PEOPLE
THE BY PRODUCT PEOPLE WHO HAD
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM DECIDING FOR
THEMSELVES WHERE THEY LIVE AND
WHAT OPPORTUNITIES THAT CAN
ACCESS CONTINUE TO BE EXCLUDED
SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
pWE'RE ASSESSING THE RACIAL
IMPACT OF EVERY. HOUSING POLICY
THAT WERE MAKING MUCH LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE SEATTLE AND SOME OTHER
CITIES HAVE DONE WHERE RACIAL
IMPACT ASSESSMENT IS REQUIRED.
I'M NOT ALSO WERE MAKING SURE
THAT WE DECISIONS ARE BEING
MADE FOR RENTAL HOUSING- THE
PRODUCTION ACCESS ANY POINT
THAT WE'RE CENTERING DECISION
MAKING ON THE ACTUAL PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN- HARMED BY THAT.
DECISION MAKING. SO THAT WILL
LEAD TO A NON OF. I HAVE THAT
WE- ALTERNATE TO. USING REPORT
FOR SCREENING WE NEED STRONGER
TENANT HARASSMENT POLICIES WE
NEED TO FULLY FUND OUR
DEPARTMENT FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSINGS AND FORSTMANN
ACTIVITIES WE NEED TO DO ALL OF
THESE THINGS. BUT I THINK AT
THE HEART OF IT IS THAT WE NEED
TO ACTUALLY CONSIDER NOT JUST
THAT WE'RE HOUSING PEOPLE. BUT
WHO ARE WE HOUSING BECAUSE NOT
EVERY TYPE OF HOUSING IS GOING
TO BE APPROPRIATE FOR EVERY
PERSON AND EVERY FAMILY AND
THAT THAT WILL BE DESPERATE
BASED ON THE HARMS OF THIS RED
LINING AND GOVERNMENT FEDERAL
LOCAL- GOVERNMENT POLICIES THAT
THE HARMS FROM A REAL ESTATE.
AGENCIES IN THE WHOLE PERSON
WHITE. MOVE THROUGH CONTRA OR
EXCLUDE. IS K. FROM OPERA TO
PROTECT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENT AND I DO TO OPEN IT TO
THE COME MEMBERS. FOR QUESTIONS
HOWEVER RIGHT BEFORE WE GO TO
I- I WANT TO. BRING SOMETHING
UP LET ME GROW ALL YOU YOU
MENTIONED CREDIT. AND- WE NEED
TO LOOK AT ALTERNATIVE WAYS OF
EVALUATING A PERSON OTHER THAN
JUST CREDIT HOWEVER IF- AND
CREDIT SCORES YOU KNOW RIGHT
NOW ARE BEING USED AND IF THEY
REMAIN THE MAIN MECHANISM TO
DETERMINE SOMEONE'S ACCESS TO
HIGH QUALITY HOUSING. WHAT ELSE
CAN WE DO. TO HELP PEOPLE BUILD
THEIR CREDIT. THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT
FOR MANY OF THE CLIENTS THAT I
WORK WITH THERE'S REALLY VERY
LITTLE OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD
CRACK. SO SOME OF THE REASONS
CAN INCLUDE THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
INSTITUTIONALIZED WHETHER JAILS
PRISONS ARE PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALS THEIR RECENT
IMMIGRANTS- OR AS I MENTIONED
THAT THE YOU KNOW THIRD THEY
THEY BEEN THE VICTIMS OF SUB.
LENDING AND SO I DID LISTEN TO
SOME OF THE EARLY PANEL TERMS
OF BUILDING FINANCE ASSETS BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY WHAT
WE'VE HAD TO DO FOR NUMBER OF
THE PEOPLE THAT WE WORK WITH.
IS ADVOCATES STRENUOUSLY LOOK
AT BANK STATEMENTS LOOK AT
RENTAL HISTORY MANY PEOPLE PAY
THE RENT BEFORE THEY'LL PAY
ANYTHING ELSE. LOOK AT THESE
THINGS ARE OLD FEDERAL
TORNADOES BECAUSE IF WE DO
CONTINUE TO RELY ON CREDIT.
WE'RE JUST GOING TO BE
EXCLUDING THE MOST VULNERABLE I
THINK IN PERPETUITY BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE OPPORTUNITIES
TO BUILD CREDIT. I APPRECIATE
THAT WELL WONDER THE THING
BEFORE OF AGAIN WE GO WE GO TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS.
AND THIS IS FOR ALL PANELIST
AYE I DO BELIEVE THAT
INCREASING THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SUPPLY HAS TO BE A PART
OF THE CONVERSATION. AND
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR RECENTLY- REPORT
CAME OUT THAT STATED THE STATE
LACKS A SOUND WELL COORDINATED
STRATEGY TO MOST AFFECTED
AFFECTIVELY USE ITS FINANCIAL
RESOURCES. TO SUPPORT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO I'M
CONCERNED THAT OUR EFFORTS TO
PROMOTE DIVERSITY AND
HOMEOWNERSHIP MAY SUFFER FROM
THE SAME DFICIENCIES SO. HOW
HAVE THE STATE'S PROGRAMS TO
PROMOTE HOMEOWNERSHIP
INCORPORATED RACIAL EQUITY INTO
THEIR PLANNING A PROGRAM
EXECUTION AND HOW SUCCESSFUL
HAVE THEY BEEN I GUESS FURTHER
I CAN SAY. IS THE SUFFICIENT
COORDINATION AMONG THE STATES
SEVERAL HOUSING FINANCE-
FINANCING ENTITIES TO
EFFECTIVELY TACKLE THIS. POLICY
AND POLICY CHANGE. M. ANY ANY
OF THE PANELISTS CAN RESPOND.
BUT NOT ALL AT ONCE. I THINK
THAT- I'LL BE THE BRAVE ONE AND
SAY THAT'S A TOUGH QUESTION
BECAUSE LARGELY WE DON'T
ACCOUNT FOR- RACE IN IN THESE
ALREADY AND I THINK THAT IT
ACCOUNTS IT REQUIRES US TO
RETHINK- ABOUT HOW WE ARE
LOOKING AT THIS- AND SEE IF
THEY'RE WAYS TO LOOK AT GROUPS-
BASED ON YOU KNOW THE
GENERATIONAL HISTORY OF. LACK
OF ACCESS TO- ISSUES LACK OF
ACCESS TO- EQUITY AND
PARTICIPATION IN THE
HOMEOWNERSHIP PROCESS- SO I
THINK THAT HONESTLY IT'S MORE
ABOUT A REFORMATION OF HOW WE
THINK M. AND LOOK AT THESE
POLICIES THAT'S WHY I THINK. WE
MIGHT BE. I KIND OF SILENCE ON
THIS IS. IT'S A REBUILD PROGRAM
OF SORTS. THANK YOU FOR THAT
RESPONSE AND. WITH THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO TURN IT BACK TO. SHARE
TO THAT IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS
SO I HAD A FEW QUESTIONS FOR
THE PANELISTS SO- ALL OF US
KNOW THAT OUR VISION RATES
HAVE. REALLY REFLECTED THE
INEQUITIES WHEN IT COMES TO
RACE- WONDERING WHAT
SUGGESTIONS YOU WOULD HAVE TO
US. AND HOW DO WE- BOTH DO A
BETTER JOB OF TRACKING THESE OF
ACTION RATES- SHOWCASING THE
INEQUITIES AND WHAT MORE CAN WE
DO THAT ONCE WE HAVE THIS
INFORMATION- TO CHANGE
DIFFERENT AREAS OF LAW THAT YOU
THINK WE SHOULD CHANGE. AND
THAT RELATED TO THAT WANTED TO
ASK WHAT YOU THOUGHT OF THE
PROCESS FOR REPORTING FAIR
HOUSING COMPLAINTS AT THIS
MOMENT AT THE STATE LEVEL- WHAT
FOLLOW UP INVESTIGATIONS LOOK
LIKE IF THERE'S MORE WE CAN DO
IN THAT AREA AS WELL. I
APOLOGIZE ALL SPEAK BRIEFLY ON
THIS WE- AT THEIR DISPLACEMENT
PROJECT OR THE PROCESS OF
COLLECTING AS MUCH OF ACTION
DATA AS POSSIBLE USING MORE
ADVANCED DATA SCIENCE TOOLS
SUCH AS MINING AND SCRAPING
COURT RECORDS- AND WORKING WITH
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS TO LOOK
AT RED. RIVER RESTITUTION THIS
AS WELL AS- OBTAINING NOTICES-
AND SO IT'S HARD YOU KNOW IT'S
HARD TO GET AT THE STATE OF
BECAUSE IT'S HIDDEN AND MOST
NATIONAL EFFORTS TO COLLECT
THIS DATA HAVE. FALLEN SHORT ON
THE WEST COAST AND SO WE'RE
TRYING TO SUPPLEMENT THAT- I
THINK SOME OF THE EFFORTS IN
SAN FRANCISCO PARTICULARLY A
RENTAL REGISTRY THAT HELPS-
IDENTIFY. SEVERAL THINGS THAT
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
UNDERSTANDING THIS PROCESS ONE
HOW MUCH- A RENTAL UNIT COSTS-
IT WAS THEIR VACANCY WATER THE
PROCESS SEES AND ALSO THE
REPORTING STRATEGIES. WHEN IT
COMES TO THE BIG FAN OR
COMPLAINT. THERE NEEDS TO BE
KIND OF A BETTER COLLECTION
SERVICE BECAUSE OTHERWISE IT'S
GOING TO REQUIRE. USING SOME-
AT. BUT IT'S GOING REQUIRES TO.
NOT REALLY NO WHAT THE STATE OF
ADDICTION WILL BE FOR WHILE
UNTIL THIS IS COLLECTED OR
REQUIRED ADVANCED TOOLS AND
EXPENSIVE- PROJECTS TO TRY AND
COLLECT SOME SORT OF
UNDERSTANDING OR AT LEAST GET A
SIGNAL WHAT'S GOING ON I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
ISSUES RIGHT NOW IS WE JUST
DON'T KNOW HOW BAD. THE THE
HOLE IN THE SHIP IS- IN
PARTICULAR- BUT WE WITH LITTLE
DATA WE CAN MAKE BIG PROGRESS
IN AND- C. BIG CHANGES. SPACES
BORN JUST MENTIONED- A COUPLE
YEARS AGO I HI READ- TRULY
OUTSTANDING WORK- BY MATTHEW
DESMOND- THE HIS FAMOUS EVICTED
POVERTY AND PROFIT- AND- HIS
ANALYSIS OF THE DATA. IN
MILWAUKEE AND IN THAT PART OF
THE COUNTRY REALLY OPENED MY
EYES UP TO WHAT MORE WE COULD
ONLY CALIFORNIA BUT AS YOU WELL
KNOW AS I'VE DISCUSSED WITH
HIM- TO YOUR POINT WE JUST
DON'T HAVE THAT DATA AND- VERY
MUCH WOULD BE OPEN TO IDEAS AND
HOW WE CAN DO A BETTER JOB OF
UNDERSTANDING THE DATA BECAUSE-
I THINK ONCE WE HAVE THE DATA.
IT WILL- REALLY DRIVE THE CASE
FOR WHY WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
THINGS DIFFERENTLY SO-
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS ON
THAT- AT. SECOND QUESTION HAVE-
AND I BELIEVE- I THINK IT WAS
MISS BLOCK FROM THE NATIONAL
HOUSING LAW PROJECT HE- WAS
TALKING ABOUT THIS. YOU
DISCUSSED CRIME FREE HOUSING
AND NUISANCE ORDINANCES AND
THEIR DISPARATE RACIAL IMPACT.
WONDERING IF OTHER STATES ARE
DOING INNOVATIVE THINGS. IN THE
AREA OF CRIME FREE HOUSING AND
NUISANCE ORDINANCES THAT THAT
WE SHOULD BE CONSIDERING IN
CALIFORNIA- YES I MEAN THIS IS
REALLY AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO LEAD ON THIS
ISSUE. OTHER STATES HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO COMPREHENSIVELY-
BAND OUR PRION'S- NUISANCE AND
CRIME FREE HOUSING ORDINANCES
DAY PASSED SIMILAR PROTECTIONS
TO THE BILL THAT YOU
CHAMPIONED- AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTEEN- TO ADDRESS- SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE- BEING
AFFECTED FOR CALLING FOR POLICE
OR EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE. BUT
THERE HAVE NOT BEEN VERY
INNOVATIVE OUR SUCCESSFUL
SOLUTIONS TO MORE
COMPREHENSIVE- BANS THIS IS
SOMETHING THE OTHER STATES ARE
ACTIVELY WORKING ON RIGHT NOW
SO CALIFORNIA HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. BE OUT IN THE
LEAD HERE. THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND WITHOUT ANY WELL BECAUSE
WITH THAT I WAS JUST GOING TO
OPEN UP FOR ANY FINAL COMMENTS
THEY MIGHT HAVE- ANY OF THE
PANELISTS BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT PANEL. AND WITH THAT I
THINK THE STRUCTURE WILL TURN
IT BACK TO YOU FOR THE FINAL
PANEL. CREATES APPRECIATE TO
THE SECOND PANEL A VERY.
ENLIGHTENING LET'S NOT GO TO
THE THIRD AND FINAL PANEL FOR
TODAY REVERSING RACIAL
INEQUITIES AND HOMELESSNESS-
OUR NEXT WITNESS WILL BE TO
MAKE A MOSS THE FOUNDER AND-
CHIEF EXECUTIVE AT ALL HOME. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME- MY NAME IS
TO MICAH MAS AND I'LL BE
SHARING A BRIEF PRESENTATION.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION. ROSS IF YOU WANT TO
START YOUR PRESENTATION. YES I
AM ACTIVELY DOING THAT AND I'LL
STARBURSTS AND IT'S GOOD TO SEE
FOR THE SECOND TIME TODAY
AMAZON TO TALK ABOUT HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS. YOU TOO THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT'S WE
COULDN'T DO IT WITHOUT HIM- LET
ME JUST. CONCEDED SELECTION
BAKER WHO. SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THE CAMELS
TODAY ARE REALLY INTERRELATED
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE- SO I'M I'M
REALLY EXCITED THAT FOLKS
UNDERSTAND THE INTERSECTIONAL
NATURE OF HOMELESSNESS WITH OUR
HOUSING CRISIS BECAUSE I THINK
IT CONTINUES TO BE- CRITICAL TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE GROUPS OF
HOMELESSNESS IS REALLY ABOUT
SAID JUST A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
ALL HOME WE ARE A BAY AREA
ORGANIZATION THAT FOCUSES ON
REGIONAL SOLUTIONS THAT DISRUPT
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING
INSECURITY AND REALLY CENTERS
ARE WORK AROUND RACIAL
INEQUITIES- AND SO ON AGAIN
REALLY GRATEFUL I FOR THE
COMMITTEE- LIFTING THIS UP
TODAY- WE THINK ALSO THAT THAT
HOUSING SECURITY AND ECONOMIC
SECURITY. ARE INEXTRICABLY
LINKED AND IN ORDER TO- ADDRESS
THE RACIAL DISPARITIES THAT
EXIST WITHIN THE HOMELESSNESS
POPULATION IT'S CRITICAL TO
ALSO EVALUATE THE ECONOMIC-
IMMOBILITY THAT EXISTS FOR MANY
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
IN IN- THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AS WELL AS IN THE BAY AREA. SO
I WANTED TO JUST WALK US
THROUGH A LITTLE BIT NAY AND
MUCH OF MY PRESENTATION IS
GOING TO BE ON THE BAY AREA
CONTACTS BUT JUST TO REALLY
ILLUSTRATE HOW SIGNIFICANT THIS
CHALLENGES- BLACK CALIFORNIANS
MANY WE ALREADY KNOW THIS THIS
DATA IS VERY EXPLICIT- AROUND
THE DISPROPORTIONAL IDEA OF HOW
MANY- BACKGROUND IN INDIGENOUS
FOLKS IN THE GENERAL
POPULATION- IN THEIR OVER
REPRESENTATION IN THE
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION. AND I
WANTED TO LEAD WITH TALKING
ABOUT SORT OF THE STRUCTURAL
DRIVERS AROUND WHY THIS THESE
DISPARITIES EXIST- I'M AND I'M
BALLIN BLIND THEM HERE THERE
ARE MANY OTHERS BUT FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THESE SORT OF
REPRESENT HOW WE GOT HERE IN
THE FIRST PLACE IN THE
CONDITIONS THAT PERPETUATE
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE. INCOME
INEQUALITY AND LACK OF INCOME
ECONOMIC MOBILITY IS PERVASIVE
AND I THINK YOU'VE SEEN THAT
TREND THROUGHOUT THE
PRESENTATIONS THIS AFTERNOON-
ESPECIALLY THE HISTORIC CONTEXT
OF STRUCTURAL RACISM THAT HAS.
REALLY SORT OF CREATED THE
CONTAINER IN WHICH-
HOMELESSNESS EXISTS- OUR RACIAL
WEALTH GAP THE LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING VERY
EXPLICIT ANTI BLACK HOUSING
POLICIES WHICH MUCH OF OUR-
SOCIETY HAS BEEN CREATED ON I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK
THAT UP AS WELL AS THE OVER
EXPOSURE TO THE CHILD WELFARE
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEMS
THESE STRUCTURAL DRIVERS. ARE
THE REASONS WHY YOU SEE SUCH A
DESPERATE IMPACT ON THE BY PARK
COMMUNITY WITH RESPECT TO
HOMELESSNESS AND IT SORT OF
OUTLINED- AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
SLIDE SOME EXAMPLES OF HOW
COMMUNITIES ARE REALLY TAKING
THIS ON AND ON AND CONFRONTING
THESE DISPARITIES BECAUSE IF.
WE DON'T TAKE IT ON HEAD ON.
DOUBLE ON. AND TORE THOSE TO.
IN OUR PROGRAMS HOMELESSNESS
SYSTEMS AND OUTCOMES THAT WERE
ACTUALLY NOT GOING TO REVERSE
THEM AND I WANTED TO JUST
HIGHLIGHT WHAT CONTRA COSTA IS
DOING IN TERMS OF ITS RACIAL
EQUITY ASSESSMENT RELATIVE TO
HOMELESSNESS. AND BY
DISAGGREGATED DATA BY RACE THEY
ARE ABLE TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHO'S ACCESSING WHAT SERVICES
ARE THE SERVICES THAT
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE AND HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
TARGETING THE APPROPRIATE
RESOURCES TO THE APPROPRIATE
PEOPLE. THIS SLIDE- JUST KIND
OF BRINGS HOME- VERY CLEARLY
AND OF COURSE THIS IS PRE
PANDEMIC DATA SO- WANTING TO
REFLECT HERE JUST THE
SIGNIFICANT DISPROPORTIONATE
ALITY IN- BLACK AND INDIGENOUS
HOUSEHOLDS IN PARTICULAR. FIVE
PERCENT- AT MORE THAN FIVE
TIMES- THE GENERAL POPULATION
OF BLACK AMERICANS IN THE BAY
AREA- ARE REPRESENTED IN THE
HOMELESS POPULATION AND TWELVE
TIMES IN THE INDIGENOUS
POPULATION SO AGAIN. DATA IS
IMPORTANT BUT THE TO SHOULD BE
A CATALYST FOR FIGURING OUT
WHAT IMPACT WE NEED TO DO ABOUT
IT AND I THINK THAT THAT'S A
LOT OF OUR CONVERSATION. TODAY
I WANTED TO ALSO JUST ED
ILLUSTRATES- THE WEALTH GAP.
RIGHT ME WE OFTEN HEAR THESE
STATISTICS WE SEE THE SLIDES
BUT THIS IS PERVASIVE THIS GOES
BACK FROM. NINETEEN NINEY TWO
TO TWENTY SIXTEEN AND WE KNOW
THESE TREND LINES ARE PRETTY
CONSISTENT. WITH HOW EVEN WITH
MORE AWARENESS AROUND RACIAL
EQUITY IN UNDERSTANDING THE
COMPLEXITY OF WHAT'S GOING ON
FOR INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITIES
THESE TREND LINES PROCESS SO I
THINK THAT IT'S- IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. TO NOT ONLY.
UNDERSTAND THE DATA BUT THEN
TAKE ACTION AROUND TRYING TO
CHIP THOSE TREND LINES. AND
THEN YOU KNOW RELATIVE TO THE
ASSET BUILDING I KNOWINGLY
EARLIER ON PANELS YOU TALKED
ABOUT HOMEOWNERSHIP AND RENTAL
HOUSING YOU KNOW THIS REALLY
DEMONSTRATES HOW THE STIGMA
THAT EXISTS AROUND SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING AND REFLECTING THAT IN
FACT OUR HIGHER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS ON THE ECONOMIC
SPECTRUM. AND PREDOMINANTLY
WHITE HOUSEHOLDS ACTUALLY
RECEIVE A PUBLICLY SUBSIDIZED
TAX SUBSIDY UP FOR THEIR
HOUSING BUT WE HAVE A MUCH
HARDER TIME FIGURING OUT
SUBSIDIZED SOLUTIONS FOR PEOPLE
ALONG THE LOWER ECONOMIC
ECONOMIC SPECTRUM AND SO I
WANTED TO JUST ILLUSTRATE HERE
THAT- TAX SUBSIDIES ARE BUILT
INTO HOW IN FACT PEOPLE-
ACQUIRE WEALTH IN A CHOIR
HOUSING AND WE NEED TO. HAVE
EQUITY AROUND THOSE THOSE
SUBSIDIES- IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE DISPARITIES THAT EXCESS.
AND THEN THIS IS JUST ANOTHER
REFLECTION WE'VE ALSO JUST JUST
CONCLUDED THE RENOWNED- COUNTS
THIS IS JUST AN ILLUSTRATION OF
THE DEARTH- HOUSING FOR PEOPLE
WITH EXTREMELY LOW INCOMES IN
THE BAY AREA IN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WHERE WE ARE
PUTTING OUR EMPHASIS ON OUR
DEVELOPMENT PIPELINES. WE SEE
HERE THAN ABOVE MODERATE.
pPRODUCED DISPROPORTIONATELY TO
WHERE WE NEED IT THE MOST WHICH
IS THE LOWER END OF THE
ECONOMIC A SPECTRUM AND AGAIN.
CONSISTENT WITH THE TREND LINES
THAT WE'RE SEEING BASED ON THE
SHORTAGE OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
THAT EXIST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR OUR FORMALLY
HOMELESS AND- AN EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND I ALSO
WOULD SAY. WE HAVE HAD A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT PARADIGM AROUND THE
ONLY HOUSING WE THINK ABOUT FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IS PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT ALL HOME IS
REALLY TRYING TO DO IS SHIFT
THAT NARRATIVE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT NOT EVERYONE NEEDS. DEEPLY
NEEDS SUPPORTED HOUSING A LOT
OF FOLKS JUST NEED DEEPLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT THEIR
INCOMES CAN COVER AND SO YOU
MAY HAVE PEOPLE WHO NEED SOME
SERVICES BUT THEY DON'T NEED
ONGOING COMPREHENSIVE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. SO WE THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO LOOK
AT THE CONTINUUM OF NEED AND
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE HOUSING
OPTIONS THAT MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ACCESSING
SERVICES- THIS THIS LINE IS
JUST A REFLECTION I THINK OF I
THINK IT WAS ME MERIEL OR THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER REALLY-
TALKING ABOUT LISTENING TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING A
CRISIS AND BEING VERY COMPLAIN
ABOUT HOW WE TRY TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM DOESN'T NEED TO BE THIS
COMPLEX BUREAUCRACY THAT WE
CREATED IT ACTUALLY CAN BE VERY
SIMPLE IF WERE LISTENING AND
CENTERING THE VOICES OF PEOPLE
WITH LIVED EXPERTISE EXPERIENCE
AND SO I JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT HERE. TO HELP PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN THIS CRISIS TALK
ABOUT IT AND HOW AS
POLICYMAKERS AND LEADERS OF
ORGANIZATIONS HOW WE NEED TO
REALLY LISTEN AND INTERPRET NOT
NOT USE OUR OWN INTERPRETATION
BUT REALLY HEAR WHAT PEOPLE
NEED AND FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
CREATE POLICIES TO DELIVER ON
THOSE SPEEDS AND THIS IS JUST A
COUPLE OF AB REFLECTIONS
DIRECTLY FROM- THE SOME FOLKS
THAT WE'VE INTERVIEWED DURING
THE CALL THE CRISIS IN
PARTNERSHIP. WITH THE NATIONAL
INNOVATION SERVICE- THE GOOD
NEWS IT IS FOLKS IN COMMUNITY
ARE ALREADY WORKING ON THIS I
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT SOME
EFFORTS HAPPENING ACROSS THE
BAY AREA DESTINATION HOME- DID
A RACE AND HOMELESSNESS REPORT
RECENTLY WHERE THEY ARE-
HIGHLIGHTING A COUPLE OF VERY
KEY STRATEGIES TO ENSURE. THAT
BEARER ADDRESSING THE RACIAL
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST IN THEIR
COMMUNITY- ALAMEDA COUNTY OF
COURSE IN THE CITY OF OAKLAND
IN FACT HAS BEEN SORT OF. A
PIONEERING SOME OF THIS WORK
AND IS REFLECTED IN SOME OF THE
ANALYSIS AND SYSTEMS MODELING
THAT THEY HAVE DONE ACROSS. THE
COUNTY IN THE CITY'S- AND THEN
OF COURSE SAN FRANCISCO DID-
AND THEN AN ASSESSMENT AS WELL
AROUND THERE HOMELESSNESS
SYSTEM. AND SOME OF THESE
BULLET POINTS SORT OF REFLECT.
VERY TACTICAL INTERVENTIONS
AROUND ASSESSING RESEARCH
RACIAL EQUITY. OUT OF YOUR
PROGRAMS AND IMPLEMENTATION TO
ENSURE THAT YOU CAN COURSE
CORRECT AND IF YOU'RE SEEN
DISPARITIES PERSIST PROCESS
LIKE WE HAVE SEEN IN SOME
COORDINATED ENTRY SYSTEMS FOR
EXAMPLE YOU CAN REALLY TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE THE
DISPARITIES ARE ARE PERSISTING.
AND HOW DO YOU GET IT THOSE AND
YOU KNOW. REALLY FREE DESIGNER-
READ MORE ENSURE STRATEGIES. SO
THE LAST TWO SLIDES HERE MY
PRESENTATION OR JUST SORT OF
WHAT I THINK WE CAN DO ABOUT IT
RIGHT IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS AS I SAID
WITH LIVED EXPERTISE AND
EXPERIENCE ARE NOT JUST AT THE
TABLE TO HEAR WHAT'S HAPPENING
FOR THEM. BUT THAT THERE ARE
PART OF THE PROGRAMMING THEY'RE
PART OF THE POLICY MAKING THE
FUNDING DECISIONS RIGHT HOW DO
WE ACTUALLY HAVE THE COURAGE TO
ENSURE THAT RESOURCES ARE GOING
DIRECTLY TO THE PROBLEMS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE. WHEN YOU
DON'T FOCUS ON SOMETHING IT
DOESN'T GET DONE. APPLYING A
RACIAL IN EQUITY LENS ALWAYS
REALLY MEANS. NOT JUST DOING IT
AT THE FRONT END OF YOUR SYSTEM
BUT REALLY TESTING OUT ITS
IMPLEMENTATION WHETHER OR NOT
YOU WERE SEEN THE DISPARITIES
THAT THAT PROCESS- NUMBER THREE
I THINK IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND SPEAKS TO. ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MEMBER ASKED EARLIER
ABOUT CREDIT. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT STRUCTURAL RACISM MUCH OF
HOW OUR HOUSING POLICIES WERE
DESIGNED ARE REALLY IN THAT IT
IS IN STRUCTURAL RACISM AND
EXCLUSION. OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
PEOPLE BLACK BROWN AND
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE IN PARTICULAR
SO WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND AND
TEST OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
STRUCTURAL RACISM THROUGHOUT
EVERY INTERVENTION THAT WE HAVE
AND SO I THINK THAT KIND OF
BROWN'S ARE WORKING I REALLY- I
THINK IT'S HARD FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND SORT OF HOW.
STRUCTURAL RACISM SHOWS UP IN
SPECIFIC POLICIES AND I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO CHALLENGE OURSELVES
AROUND THAT. LAST POINT HERE IS
JUST AS I SAID HOUSING SECURITY
AND ECONOMIC SECURITY ARE
REALLY- CONNECTED AND WE NEED
TO BE DOING INTERRELATED POLICY
WORK IN ADVOCACY TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE. NOT ONLY THINKING ABOUT
OUR SUPPLY A PRESERVATION AND
PROTECTION OF TENANTS AND
HOUSING BUT WE'RE ALSO THINKING
ABOUT HOW DO WE INCREASE
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE. ARE ABLE TO STAY
IN THEIR HOMES IN THE FIRST
PLACE. AND THEN THIS IS MY
FINAL SLIDE JUST LIFTING UP TO
ME YOU KNOW THIS ISN'T A CHOICE
THAT'S WHY I'M SO HONORED TO BE
HERE WITH YOU TODAY IF WE'RE
REALLY TALKING ABOUT HOUSING
JUSTICE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE TO BE
TALKING ABOUT RACIAL JUSTICE
THE HISTORIC- DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES PROCESS IT'S A FACT
WE HAVE IMPERIAL EMPIRICAL DATA
TO SUPPORT THAT AND I THINK
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
KEEP THAT AT THE FOREFRONT OF
OUR MINDS AS WE TRY TO TACKLE
THIS CHALLENGE. THE LAST THING
I WOULD SAY BEFORE I TURN IT
OVER- BACK OVER TO THE
COMMITTEE IS ALL HOME IS REALLY
FOCUSING ON THE FULL SPECTRUM
OF INTERVENTIONS THAT RELATE TO
HOMELESSNESS SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE IT REALLY REQUIRES
AN INVESTMENT IN PREVENTION HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT HOUSEHOLDS
DON'T BECOME HOMELESS IN THE
FIRST PLACE HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO
RENTAL ASSISTANCE LEGAL
SERVICES AND SO FORTH TO KEEP
THEM HOUSED IN THE FIRST PLACE
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
RECOGNIZING THAT THE BROTHERS
AND SISTERS WHO ARE ON THE
STREET TODAY NEED TO BE BROUGHT
INDOORS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
IT IS UNACCEPTABLE FOR US TO
ALLOW OUR NEIGHBORS TO LANGUISH
ON THE STREET. WHILE WE BUILD
ENOUGH HOUSING FOR EVERYONE SO
WE THINK IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF INTERIM HOUSING
OPTIONS AND THAT COULD BE
ANYTHING FROM A SUBSIDY TO- NON
CONGREGATE SHELTER WHATEVER WE
NEED TO DO TO KEEP PEOPLE
INSIDE AND SAFE SO THAT WE CAN
SIMULTANEOUSLY BE LOOKING FOR
PERMANENT HOUSING EXITS WHICH
IS THE ULTIMATE GOAL WE BELIEVE
THAT EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA
EVERYONE IN THE BAY AREA
DESERVES A SAFE AND AFFORDABLE
PLACE TO LIVE AND WE THINK IF
WE ARE DOING ALL THREE OF THOSE
THINGS PREVENTION INTERIM
HOUSING AND PERMANENT HOUSING
SIMULTANEOUSLY AND MAKING
INVESTMENTS IN THOSE SYSTEMS
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
SEE A POPULATION LEVEL
REDUCTION. IN HOMELESSNESS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
FOR PRESENT IS MORE. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM THE
PROFESSOR- FROM THE RECTOR OF
RESEARCH EVALUATION AT THE
NATANSON FAMILY RESILIENCE
CENTER AT UCLA PROFESSOR NOR
RITA NUMBER. STILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON I WANT TO THANK FONG
CHAIRS CHIU AND GRAYSON AND THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE AND THE
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
FOR THE INVITATION TO SPEAK
TODAY I AM PRESENTING FINDINGS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS FROM A
RECENTLY COMPLETED MIXED
METHODS STUDY OF RETENTION AND
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
FOR BLACK CLIENTS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY CONDUCTED
THROUGH THE POLICY OF THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB AT UCLA
THIS STUDY GREW OUT OF OUR WORK
WITH THE LOS ANGELES HOUSING
SERVICES OF PARTY OR LHASA. AD
HOC COMMITTEE ON PEOPLE WITH
LIVED IT. OF HOMELESSNESS SO
ARE MIXED METHODS APPROACH
INCLUDES BOTH QUANTITATIVE AND
QUALITATIVE FINDINGS WE FOCUSED
ON RACIAL INEQUITIES AND
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
EXPERIENCE THAT IS RETURNS TO
HOMELESSNESS AMONG BLACK
CLIENTS WE EXAMINED
QUANTITATIVE ADMINISTRATIVE
DATA FROM A HOMELESS. BUT AS
MANAGEMENT INFORMATION SYSTEM
FY I HMIS TO ESTIMATED RETURN
OR ITS OWN RACE ETHNICITY FROM.
TWO THOUSAND TEN TO TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WE COLLECTED
QUALITATIVE DATA AND TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY VIA INTERVIEWS
AND FOCUS FROM GROUPS WITH A
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
PROGRAM- AND CASE MANAGERS AND
LYFT CLIENTS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHY BLACK CLIENTS
WERE RETURNING PEOPLE
HOMELESSNESS. WE FOUND
POLITICAL ENDS ARE THE LARGEST
GROUP OF SINGLE ADULT CLIENTS
IN PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
AND ARE THE MOST LIKELY TO
RETURN CALL LISTENERS. WE
BELIEVE THEIR PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PLACEMENT
AND RETURN TO AND AN ARM
HOUSING ARE LIVING ON THE
STREETS IN LOS ANGELES
BLACKLINE'S ARE 38% MORE LIKELY
TO RETURN TO HOMELESSNESS THEN
WHY CLIENTS. SO THE MAJOR
THINGS THAT IN THAT REGION ARE
QUALITATIVE FINDINGS WERE WHITE
BLACK CLIENTS EXIT HOMELESS- OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
AND RETURNED HOMELESSNESS R.
ONE PERMANENT. SUPPORTIVE HELLO.
HELLO PROGRAM AND LYFT VOLUME
HAVE BEEN PERCENT. OF THE- OF
SUPPORTIVE. PROGRAM MANAGERS
REPORT. PERCEIVING PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AS A LONG
TERM HOUSING SOLUTION BLACK
LIVES REPORT PRECEDING FIRST
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AS
SHORT TERM HOUSING SOLUTION AS
A STEPPING STONE TO PERMANENT
HOUSING SUCH AS JANET AID
HOUSING. TO SOME BLACK CLIENTS
EXIT PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING DUE TO SPENDING
CONCERNS ABOUT HOUSING AT
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY AND
EXPERIENCES OF SEGREGATION
DISCRIMINATION AND STEPPER.
EXPENDITURES FOR POOR BLACK
CLIENTS RECALLS IT HISTORICALLY
AND CURRENTLY RACIAL AND ETHNIC
SEGREGATED COMMUNITIES AND
HOUSING WERE INLAND PORTS WERE
MORE LIKELY TO ACCEPT BLACK
CLIENTS PROGRAM AND CASE
MANAGERS REPORTED BLACK CLIENTS
WERE HELD TO STRICTER LEAST
LEASE AGREEMENTS THEN ON BLACK
CLIENTS. AND PERCEIVED AS MORE
DANGEROUS UNINTELLIGENT OR
MENTALLY INCOMPETENT AND ON
BLACK CLIENTS BY SOME PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING STAFF. BLACK
CLIENTS REPORTED THEY WERE NOT
TREATED AS ADULTS OR
DEHUMANIZED AND EXPERIENCED.
PREJUDICE FROM SOME OF OUR
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
STAFF THREE SOME OF MY CLIENTS
AND SAID PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING DUE TO AN ADEQUATE CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES. CASE
MANAGEMENT TURNOVER IS HIGH
BECAUSE OF THE LOW SALARIES-
BUILDING TRUST BETWEEN OUR
CLIENTS IS LIMITED BY THE LACK
OF CASE MANAGERS WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE A LACK OF BLACK CASE
MANAGERS PROGRAM AND CASE
MANAGERS. REPORTED STARTING
SALARIES. WHERE A LOT OF
RELATIVES IN TO THE CAR WILL IN
AND APOSS ANGELES. AND CASEMENT
OFTEN WE FROM AGENT. AGENTS
FIRST CELL INCREASE. BLACK INS
REPORT THE NEED FOR MORE PEER
NOW WILL PUT EXPERIENCE K.
MANAGER REPORT THAT. AND TRUST
ONE EXCUSE. PROGRAM ADDED
REPORTED THAT RECRUITMENT
RETENTION OF CASE MANAGERS
SHOULD FOCUS ON CASE MANAGERS
OF COLOR INCLUDING ADDRESSING
BIAS. IN THE PROVINCE. HOW'S IT
WORKING. SO ARE RECOMMEND FOR
THE JUST. TO BE KEPT DRESSED
INEQUITIES THE RETENTION OF
BLACKLINE IN PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING R. ONE AUDIT
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
PLACEMENTS FOR EQUITY AND
INCLUSION TO SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AND CAPACITY FOR
INVESTIGATION OF ENFORCEMENT
AGAINST FAIR HOUSING VIOLATIONS
THE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING. THREE MANDATE INLAND
FAIR HOUSING RULES AND
REGULATIONS AND BEST PRACTICES
PLEASE S. AND STRUCTURAL AND
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM ACROSS
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
PROGRAMS. THREE SUPPORT FUNDING
FOR PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING CASE MANAGEMENT TO
PROVIDE CASE MANAGEMENT FOR
CLIENTS UP TO A YEAR AFTER THAT
EXUBERANCE. HOUSING THE
CREATION OF A CASE MANAGEMENT
CAREER. WITH CONSISTENT I'D
LINES ACROSS AT THE PORT OF
HOUSING PROGRAMS FOR BOTH COST
OF LIVING INCREASES AND MERIT
BASED PROMOTIONS- ON. AND
REGULAR INTERESTING CASE
MANAGER. OF I'M TRUMP PRACTICE
COMMUNITIES. AND RESOURCES AND
OTHER AREAS LIKE ENOUGH BY CASE
MANAGERS AS SUBSTANTIAL FOR
THEIR PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT-
LAST SUPPORT FUNDING TO DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT GUIDELINES ACROSS
PERMANENCE OF HEALTH PROGRAMS
FOR PEER ADVOCATES TO HELP
TRANSITION PEOPLE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE OF HOMELESSNESS INTO
CASE MANAGEMENT GROUP ROLE CASE
MANAGER PIPELINE SO THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR. TIME AND
ATTENTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION WE ASK IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. THAT'S ENOUGH I
HAVE A FEW- WOULD LIKE TO ASK
BOTH OF YOU. THERE IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
MOVE AT LEAST ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR HOMELESSNESS- TO MOVE FOR A
NUMBER OF FRONTS AND WONDERING.
WHAT YOU THINK OF AS FAR AS
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
VALUATION METRICS THAT OUR
STATE SHOULD CONSIDER- AS WE
PROVIDE THIS MONEY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE. TRACKING AND
HOPEFULLY ADDRESSING THESE
DISPARITIES AND- ASSUMING WE
IDENTIFY THESE DISPARITIES WHAT
WOULD BE YOUR TOP STRATEGIES
FOR ELIMINATED THEM. HAPPY FOR
YOU TO YOUR ANSWER. I'M SORRY I
WAS HAVING TROUBLE TAKING
MYSELF OFF OF NEW I THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION- I THINK ONE
OF THE- HE STRATEGIES IS MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE A WAY TO
STANDARDIZE OUR DATA. PRACTICES
AND HELPING TO INCENTIVIZE
LOCALITIES. DISAGGREGATE THEIR
DATA BY RACE AND ETHNICITY- AND
HAVING THAT LEADERSHIP FROM THE
STATE TO INCENTIVIZE THAT TYPE
OF DATA COLLECTION I THINK
WOULD BE REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT- BECAUSE HE YOU KNOW.
WE ALSO CAN USE GEOGRAPHIC
TARGETING- WHERE THERE IS IT
THERE IS A DISPROPORTIONATE-
GRANT BURDEN- THE AND I THINK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO YOU TALKED
EARLIER ABOUT HOUSEHOLDS PAYING
3250% OF THEIR INCOME TO RENT
MOST OF THE COMMUNITIES
PARTICULARLY- WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED ARE
PAYING EIGHTY TO A 100% OF
THEIR INCOME TO RENT AND SO I
THINK WE CAN. REALLY FOCUS ON
METRICS THAT. ALIGN WITH WHERE
THE PEOPLE ARE EXPERIENCING-
THERE HOUSING CRISIS FOCUSING
ON THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS AND- AND
CENSUS TRACTS AS WELL AS-
HAVING A STANDARDIZED DATA
COLLECTION SYSTEM THAT
LOCALITIES BUYING INTO THAT THE
STATE SUPPORTS THAT INCLUDES
INCOME- BRAZEN ETHNICITY DATA
SO THAT WE CAN THEN THE-
PROPORTION OUR RESOURCES TOWARD
REDUCING THOSE DISPARITIES. AND
THEN THE OTHER THING I'D SAY
IS- THE INTERVENTIONS THAT WE
TYPICALLY USE FOR FOLKS WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESS
HOMELESSNESS BEARING BYE. BY
ETHNICITY- AS AS AS
COMMUNICATED BY MY COLLEAGUES
AND SO. NOT EVERYONE NEEDS
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING SO
HOW DO WE LOOK AT-
INCENTIVIZING SHALLOW SUBSIDIES
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE I THINK THE- HOUSE
OF HOMELESSNESS- SYSTEM IS
REALLY FOCUSED ON CREDIT
SITTING. AND THE LONGER PEOPLE
END UP BEING EXPOSED TO
HOMELESSNESS THE MORE SUPPORT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE BUT IF WE
CAN GO A BIT UPSTREAM AND
INSURE THAT WHEN PEOPLE SEEK
HELP. THEY CAN GET THAT HELP
SOMETIMES IT'S AS LITTLE AS
THREE OR FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS
MAKES THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
WHETHER OR NOT SOMEONE BECOMES
HOMELESS OR NOT AND SO REALLY
THINKING ABOUT HOW DO WE
DISTRIBUTE RESOURCES THAT
PROVIDE. ACCESS TO LOWER
SERVICE. NEEDS IN ADDITION TO
AGAIN BUILDING OUT AS MUCH
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AS WE CAN IN
PROVIDING PERMANENT HOMES FOR
PEOPLE WITH EXTREMELY LOW
INCOMES. I THINK MIGHT BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION. SO WHAT I'M
GOING TO JUST READ. WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE ON THIS LAW SAYS SAID
PIPE. BOMB ONE OF THE IT IS
BECAUSE WE DO NEED TO
DISAGGREGATE DATA BY BRITAIN'S
F. THIRTY WE DO NEED TO SEE
THAT CONSISTENTLY ACROSS THE
STATE WE DO THAT
DISAGGREGATION. A WITHIN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND WE DO RELY
ON THE H. MY HAS SYSTEM WHICH
DOES PROVIDE THIS APPLICATION
SO THAT'S ONE. POINT. THAT I
WILL PUT IT RIGHT. SO POINT
THAT I WILL TO READ. THAT COMES
THROUGH OUR FINDINGS AND WAS
SPOKEN TO BY A SMALL SWITCH IS
TRULY INCLUDE THE VOICES OF
PEOPLE WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE IN
DECISION MAKING PROCESS THAT
THERE WAS A WAY. TO INCENTIVIZE
SOME OF THAT IN THE DATA
COLLECTION PROCESS THAT WOULD
BE GOOD AND THE THIRD PIECE IS
REALLY UNDERSTANDING. THAT
THERE REALLY IS VERY XIN AMONG
PEOPLE WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE
WITH DIFFERENT NEEDS AND
ATTENTION TO BOTH. I DO THINK
UPSTREAM PREVENTIVE PEACE IS
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE SINCE WE
HEARD IN OUR SMALL STUDY WITH.
OUR SMALL SAMPLE OF
PARTICIPANTS EVERYONE DOES NOT
SEE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING IT IS THE END WROTE AND
EVERYONE DOES NOT NEED. THE
TYPE OF SERVICES THAT- PLIGHT
AND PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING THERE IS A VARIATION OF
WE NEED TO GIVE YOUR ATTENTION
TO THAT. AND ARE FROM. THANK
YOU THANK ONE FINAL QUESTION-
YEAR OF A BILL AB TWENTY EIGHT.
WHICH IS TRYING TO ADDRESS THE
REVOLVING DOOR BETWEEN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
HOMELESSNESS GIVEN THAT. WE
KNOW THAT HALF OF THE FOLKS WHO
ARE SLEEPING ON OUR STREETS OF
CALIFORNIA AT NIGHT HAVE HAD
SOME INTERACTION WITH OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO PUT
SAVINGS FROM PRISON CLOSURES
TOWARD SUPPORT OF HOUSING FOR
THOSE WERE LEAVING. THE SYSTEM
AND I WANT TO ASK WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON HOW WOULD WE BEST
DIRECT THAT MONEY- WHAT IS THE
BEST WAY FOR US TO INVEST IN TO
ENSURE THAT JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE TRYING TO
REENTER. SOCIETY GET THE
RESOURCES AND WE DO THIS IN A
WAY- THAT- THAT THAT ALLEVIATES
THE INEQUITIES OVERSEEN WITH
REGARD TO RACE. CALL ME MAYBE
I'LL- KICK US OFF AND THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION. YOU KNOW ONE
OF. THE THINGS I THINK COULD BE
HELPFUL IS. IF WE'RE ABLE TO
CONVERT THOSE SAVINGS INTO
RESOURCES THAT END UP PROVIDING
HOUSING SUPPORTS FOR FOLKS WHO-
ARE FORMERLY INCARCERATED I
ACTUALLY THINK WE NEED TO START
DOING THAT PLANNING WHILE
PEOPLE ARE STILL INCARCERATED.
BEFORE SOMEONE IS RELEASED
FIGURING OUT A HOUSING PLAN
WITH FOLKS WHO ARE ABOUT TO
LEAVE THE JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
ENSURING THAT THOSE RESOURCES
ARE ACTUALLY TIED TO THEIR
EXIT. RATHER THAN THEM HAVING
TO COME OUT AND GO SEEK- AND
FIND PROGRAMS AND SERVICES TO
MEET THEIR NEEDS I THINK- IS A
CHALLENGE AND SO PUTTING THOSE
RESOURCES ACTUALLY. ARE
ATTACHED TO BOOKS REMITTANCES
WORKING WITH PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS WORKING WITH PAROLE
AND MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE SO WHEN
SOMEONE IS INCARCERATED YOU
START THAT PLANNING SIX MONTHS
THAT YOU'RE BEFORE THEIR
RELEASE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE SEAMLESSNESS
COORDINATION BETWEEN THEIR EXIT
AND THEY DON'T HAVE TO STRUGGLE
WHEN THEY COME HOME AND TRY TO
RE INTEGRATE INTO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. WHERE TO FIND
HOUSING RESOURCES I ALSO THINK
THAT YOU KNOW AGAIN. BEING ABLE
TO DIRECTLY TIE FUNDING TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST IMPACTED
IT'S CRITICAL AND YOU KNOW THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF
PROP TWO OH NINE AND SOME OTHER
THINGS HAVE TO USE. OTHER
PROXIES TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
RACIAL DISPARITIES BUT I WONDER.
IF THERE'S A WAY IF. WE ARE
USING. THAT ARE- THAT ARE THAT
COME BACK INTO OUR COMMUNITY
BECAUSE OF PRISON CLOSURES THAT
THAT WE MAKE A DIRECT
CONNECTION TO CONNECT THOSE
RESOURCES TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY COMING OUT OF OUR OUR-
OUR SYSTEMS AND SO THOSE ARE
SOME IDEAS THAT I'VE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT IS HOW DO WE
ENSURE THAT THERE'S DIRECT
CONNECTIVE ITTY. TO THE
RESOURCES- WHEN A PERSON IS
RELEASED IN THAT THE MONEY
ACTUALLY FOLLOWS THE PERSON AND
THAT IF THE MONEY IS BEING
ADMINISTERED THROUGH COMMUNITY
BASED PROGRAMS THAT THAT PERSON
KNOWS EXACTLY WHERE TO GO
BECAUSE THAT IS A PART OF THEIR
HOUSING- PLAN AS THEY'RE BEING
RELEASED. SUPER HELPFUL I
APPRECIATE THAT. WELL LET ME
GIVE BOTH OF YOUR OPPORTUNITY
OF ANY FINAL COMMENTS YOU LIKE
TO SHARE WITH US- TO- TO
CONCLUDE TODAY'S HEARING. IF
THERE'S ANYTHING LEYVA SAID. MY
FINAL COMMENT I REALLY THINK MY
CLUB COMMENT BILLS BACKED WHO-
YOUR FOCUS ON ON. PEOPLE
LEAVING OTHER PRISON SYSTEM AND
REALLY WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
GIVE SOME THOUGHT TO WOODWARD-
LISTINGS COULD PREVIOUS SESSION
REALLY THINKING ABOUT TYING
FUNDS TO PEOPLE IS THAT LEAVING
THE SYSTEM WORKING WITH
COMMUNITY PARTNERS WORKING IN
BOTH PRO BOWL AND PROBATION BUT
REALLY THINKING IF THERE'S A
WAY TO TIE A CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM. INTO THAT PROCESS AND
TO PROVIDE SOME FUNDING FOR
CASE MANAGERS WHO REALLY CAN'T
WORK SPECIFICALLY WITH THIS
POPULATION SO THAT'S WHAT I
WOULD LEAVE YOU WITH AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO A PRESENT TODAY. THANK YOU
YEAH. THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN
FOR HAVING ME I THINK MY FINAL
REMARKS SEARCHES THAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ENTERED IN- TO
INVEST IN PREVENTION INTERIM
HOUSING AND PERMANENT HOUSING
SIMULTANEOUSLY WE NEED THAT
SYSTEM HELLO WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO CUSTOMIZE OUR INTERVENTIONS
BASED ON WHAT PEOPLE'S NEEDS
ARE AND I THINK WE HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY IF WE'RE ABLE TO
MAKE INVESTMENTS ACROSS THE
FULL CONTINUUM OF INTERVENTIONS
THAT WE NEED. THE OTHER LAST
WORD IS SCALE AND IMPACT IF WE
WANT TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE WE
NEED A PERMANENT SOURCE OF
FUNDING TO SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS
TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS AND THE
HOUSING CRISIS AND WE ARE
REALLY RELYING ON OUR STATE AND
FEDERAL PARTNERS TO HELP
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE DO
THAT AND I REALLY LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING OUR WORK
TOGETHER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I MEANT TO THAT- PERSPECTIVE
AROUND A PERMANENT SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR HOMELESSNESS AND-
WE'VE A BILL. AB SEVENTY ONE
THAT WOULD ESTABLISH THAT I
KNOW THIS CONVERSATION IS
ONGOING. SO ONE OF JUST THANK
ALL THE PANELISTS FOR THIS
GREAT DISCUSSION TODAY. I'D
LIKE TO NOW TURN TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AND SAY TO THE
OPERATOR. IF THERE ARE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. A FEW PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES. THEN LATER GERMAN
ON THE PHONE LINES IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NOT VERY WILL PROVIDE YOU
A NUMBER. AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
YOU BY THAT NUMBER. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND IF I COULD
ASK THE OPERATOR HOW MANY.
CALLERS ARE YOU IDENTIFYING. AT
THE TIME WE HAVE- ONE IN OUR
QUEUE CORRECT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. JUST A MOMENT. AND WE'LL
GO TO NUMBER SEVENTEEN NUMBER
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HOLDEN CAN RESULT FROM ONE
THIRTY CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY TO PROVIDE A SUPPORT
FOR- LOOKING AT HOUSING THEIR
RACIAL EQUITY LINE. AND WE WANT
TO SAY THAT CREATE AN EQUITABLE
HOUSING ASSEMBLY MY STRENGTH
AND PROTECTION PROVIDE
COMMUNITIES AND WE CAN FIGHT
THE CRIMINALS LAURIE AND RACIST
POLICIES BY INCREASING THE
PROTECTION EXPANDING REDUCTION
MORATORIUM FOR GIVING RENDON
INCREASING TECHNICAL ARE
INCREASING FINANCIAL SUPPORT.
WITH THE ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT WAS ALLOCATED FOR
CALIFORNIA AND FINALLY FROM
BACK THEN BY PLOTTING UNITIES
WE MUST BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WITH THE RACIAL EQUITY
LINE. AND EIGHT OKAY. ENTER
FIVE. THANK YOU. ENDOSPERM IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE TIME
THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN Q. TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS. THANK
YOU I WANT TO GET JUST THANK
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
IS HERE AND I WANT TO ASK A
SHERMAN GRAYSON FEEL ANY FINAL
COMMENTS. JUST SOME CLOSING
COMMENTS AS CHAIRMAN OF BANKING
AND FINANCE OF FOR THE
ASSEMBLY. I AM COMMITTED TO.
WORKING DILIGENTLY IN EVERY
ISSUE AREA LIKE ACCESS TO
CREDIT CREDIT REPAIR LENDING
POLICIES STATE FINANCIAL
PROGRAMS AND ALTERNATIVE
MODELS. TO HELP THOSE MOST IN
NEED ESPECIALLY. OUR LATIN ACTS
IN BLACK COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE
SUFFERED THE MOST BECAUSE OF
EXISTING AND EQUITIES AND
DISPARITIES. I DO WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR. OF HOUSING AS WELL
FOR THE HELP OF PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER. AND THE PANELIST- FOR
THEIR SUPPORT THEIR
PRESENTATIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST WANT
TO THANK ALL THE MEMBERS BUT
PARTICULARLY TE PANELISTS FOR
YOUR GREAT TESTIMONY TO GAY.
OBVIOUSLY THESE ARE VERY DEEP
AND LONGSTANDING ISSUES- BUT- I
THINK THERE MANY OF US WERE
POLICYMAKERS ARE VERY COMMITTED
TO DO ALL WE CAN TO ADDRESS
THEM SO. APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION. AGAIN I WANT TO
TAKE A MOMENT AND THANK- SAM
FAKE HOUSE WHO IS AN MVP
STUDENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
BERKELEY. UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY WORKING WITH OUR
STAFFERS SANDRA DOCTOR GALA IN
PUTTING TODAY'S HEARING ON AND-
LOOK FORWARD TO THE ONGOING
CONVERSATION WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO. WITH THAT AT THIS
TIME WE ARE GOING TO WRAP UP
TODAY'S MEETING. AND- HAVE A
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU.